This episode is brought to you by Lloyd's business and commercial banking. One of the great things about finance is that it may result in you having to pay tax. And this was a constant grumble in Anglo-Saxon England, which was the most heavily taxed country in the whole of Christendom. And just when the Anglo-Saxons thought it couldn't get any worse, they got conquered by King Canute. And Canute imposed a tax rate that was effectively... 100%. Yeah, well, that was one very big change, Tom, but another tax change is upon us. And this is the advent of making tax digital for income tax. And if you're at all concerned about it, this is where Lloyd's come in, because they're here to help make that change much simpler for
本集节目由劳埃德商业银行赞助播出。金融的一大妙处在于，它可能会让你不得不缴税。这在盎格鲁-撒克逊时代的英格兰是一个永恒的抱怨，当时它是整个基督教世界中税负最重的国家。而就在盎格鲁-撒克逊人以为情况不会再糟的时候，他们被克努特国王征服了。克努特征收的税率实际上达到了……100%。是的，汤姆，那是一个巨大的变化，但另一项税务变革也即将来临。这就是针对所得税的“税收数字化”计划。如果你对此有任何顾虑，劳埃德银行可以为你提供帮助，因为他们致力于让这一转变变得更加简单，
you with a useful HMRC-recognized accounting tool that will help you stay in line with all the making tax digital requirements. And the brilliant thing about this is, is that it is free for Lloyd's business account customers. So when it is time to digitise your income tax, you can bank on Lloyd's. Search Lloyd's business accounts to find out more. This episode is brought to you by Beer 52. A good international squad needs balance, depth and variety.
他们提供了一款实用的、经英国税务海关总署（HMRC）认可的会计工具，将帮助你符合所有税收数字化的要求。最棒的是，对于劳埃德商业账户客户，这款工具是免费的。所以，当需要将你的所得税数字化时，你可以信赖劳埃德银行。搜索“劳埃德商业账户”了解更多信息。本集节目由Beer 52赞助播出。一支优秀的国际球队需要平衡、深度和多样性。
So does a case in the fridge. With an incredible month of football ahead of us, our friends at Beer 52 have expertly curated a case of eight outstanding beers from eight different countries. We're talking Germany, the USA, Argentina, and of course a bit of home representation with England and Scotland. And the best part, it's free. Go to Beer52.com slash football and just cover £5.95 postage to get your free beers now. Inside you'll get crisp lagers, juicy pale ales and rich creamy stouts, plus tasty snacks, and Ferment Magazine.
冰箱里的啤酒也是如此。随着接下来令人难以置信的足球月到来，我们的朋友Beer 52精心挑选了一箱来自八个不同国家的八款杰出啤酒。我们说的是德国、美国、阿根廷，当然还有东道主英格兰和苏格兰的代表。最棒的是，它是免费的。前往Beer52.com/football，只需支付5.95英镑的邮费，即可立即获得你的免费啤酒。箱子里有清爽的拉格啤酒、果味浓郁的淡色艾尔啤酒和口感醇厚奶油般的世涛啤酒，还有美味的零食和《发酵》杂志。
If dark beers aren't your thing, you can choose the light case instead. It's your squad after all. After the first box, it carries on as a subscription. That's £29.95 every 28 days. However, there's no minimum commitment, and you can cancel after your free box. So that's beer52.com slash football to claim your free case of beers. A.I was supposed to take over the parts of the job you hate. Turns out, it made your job even harder.
如果你不喜欢黑啤酒，也可以选择淡啤酒组合。毕竟这是你的球队。首箱之后，它将作为订阅服务继续。每28天29.95英镑。不过，没有最低承诺，你可以在收到免费箱后取消。所以，请访问beer52.com/football领取你的免费啤酒。人工智能本应接管你讨厌的工作部分。结果发现，它让你的工作变得更难了。
Instead of doing the work, it gave you homework. ServiceNow's AI specialists get work done from start to finish. Cases get resolved, loops get closed. With ServiceNow, you can do the parts of your job you're best at and delegate the rest. To put AI to work for people, visit servicenow.com. My dear son, I received a person. your very kind and welcome letter, dated April 23rd yesterday, and I was very thankful for it. But my dear lad, it was a very great disappointment to me that you were not sent to either France
它没有帮你完成工作，反而给了你家庭作业。ServiceNow的人工智能专家可以从头到尾完成工作。案例得到解决，流程得以闭环。有了ServiceNow，你可以专注于你最擅长的工作部分，并将其他部分委派出去。要让人工智能为人类服务，请访问servicenow.com。我亲爱的儿子，我收到了你4月23日寄来的非常亲切和受欢迎的信，我对此非常感激。但我亲爱的孩子，你没有像预期的那样被派往法国
or England as you expected, but I read later on that a fleet had been sent to the Dardanelles, and I made sure that it was the Australians, and I was right. Well, my son, the Australians have done And gloriously, they have made England ring with their bravery. Mr Asquith said in the House of Commons that the Australians had fought like heroes, and that they had surpassed themselves in the annals of British warfare with their bravery. Jack, my son, my heart is fairly bursting with sorrow and with pride to think that you are amongst such a lot of brave men. now my dearest son
或英国，这让我非常失望，但我后来读到一支舰队被派往达达尼尔海峡，我确信那是澳大利亚人，我猜对了。好吧，我的儿子，澳大利亚人做得太棒了，他们以英勇的表现让英格兰为之震动。阿斯奎斯先生在下议院说，澳大利亚人像英雄一样战斗，他们的英勇在英国战争史上超越了自我。杰克，我的儿子，想到你身处这样一群勇敢的人之中，我的心充满了悲伤和自豪。现在我最亲爱的儿子，
hoping and trusting that the Lord in his great mercy will guard and protect ye in these terrible times and that he will hear my prayers for ye from your ever-loving and affectionate mother so that was Sarah Fitzpatrick a widow who lived in South Shields in Tyne and Weir in Northern England despite that she was as you could tell from my
希望并相信上帝会以他伟大的仁慈在这些可怕的时刻守护和保护你，他会听到我为你祈祷的声音，来自你永远爱你的、深情的母亲。所以，那是莎拉·菲茨帕特里克，一位住在英格兰北部泰恩-威尔郡南希尔兹的寡妇。尽管正如你从我那
expert accent and artwork there, Scottish, and she was writing to her son, Jack, in May 1915. And this letter that she wrote to Jack was found on Jack's body after he was killed by machine gunfire at Anzac Cove on the 19th of May, 1915. And he was one of perhaps 150,000 men who died on the killing fields of Glippily, but he may well be the most famous. And And Dominic, why, for those who are not Australian, why is he so famous? So the answer is that even though he was born to Scottish parents and he grew up in the northeast of England, Jack Fitzpatrick, as he was born, became one of the most celebrated Australians of the century.
专业的口音和艺术表现中听出的那样，她是苏格兰人，她是在1915年5月写信给她的儿子杰克的。这封她写给杰克的信是在1915年5月19日杰克在澳新军团湾被机枪扫射身亡后，在他的遗体上发现的。他可能是加里波利杀戮场上阵亡的15万名士兵之一，但他很可能是最著名的一位。多米尼克，对于那些不是澳大利亚人的人来说，他为什么这么出名？答案是，尽管他出生于苏格兰父母，并在英格兰东北部长大，但杰克·菲茨帕特里克（他出生时的名字）成为了本世纪最著名的澳大利亚人之一。
When he was 17, he ran away and joined the Merchant Navy. And then he deserted when he got to New South Wales and he became a coal miner and a gold digger and a ship stoker and all these kinds of odd jobs. and then when war broke out in 1914 he enlisted in the third field ambulance of the Australian Imperial Force but under his mother's maiden name so he called himself John Simpson
17岁时，他离家出走加入了商船队。当他到达新南威尔士州时，他当了逃兵，成为了一名煤矿工人、淘金者、轮船司炉工，做过各种零工。1914年战争爆发时，他加入了澳大利亚帝国部队的第三野战救护队，但用的是他母亲的婚前姓氏，所以他自称约翰·辛普森。
and he thought as you can tell from his mother's letter that he would be going back to England or to France but as we heard last time the Australians were in fact sent to Gallipoli and there this guy born Fitzpatrick but now calling himself Simpson
正如你从他母亲的信中看出的那样，他以为自己会回到英国或法国，但正如我们上次听到的，澳大利亚人实际上被派往了加里波利。在那里，这个出生时叫菲茨帕特里克，现在自称辛普森的家伙，
he became famous for using donkeys to carry wounded Anzaks down from the ravines on the front line, back down to the beach. And he became a kind of cult hero for the Anzaks with his donkeys. He was said to have rescued 300 men. And then a month into the operation, on the 19th of May, he is shot. And he becomes a sort of patriotic martyr. So in Anzac mythology, he becomes, he's a poor boy who's made good. He is an every man who has sacrificed himself for his mates.
因使用驴子将受伤的澳新军团士兵从前线的峡谷运回海滩而闻名。他成了澳新军团士兵心目中的一种偶像英雄。据说他救了300人。行动开始一个月后，即5月19日，他中弹身亡。他成为了一种爱国烈士。因此，在澳新军团的神话中，他成了一个出人头地的穷小子。他是一个为战友牺牲自己的普通人。
And of course, this image of somebody with a donkey, it kind of plays into, you know, the established images of saintly figures or martyrs or messires who are traveling by donkey or by mule or whatever. And so he becomes the supreme embodiment, the incarnation of something that was created at Gallipoli, which is the Anzac spirit. So if you look him up in the Australian Dictionary of biography,
当然，这个带着驴子的人的形象，在某种程度上迎合了人们心中既定的圣徒、烈士或弥赛亚骑驴或骑骡旅行的形象。因此，他成为了在加里波利创造的一种精神的最高体现和化身，那就是“澳新军团精神”。所以，如果你在《澳大利亚传记词典》中查阅他，
it says of him, Simpson and his donkey became a legend, the symbol of all that was pure, selfless and heroic on Gallipoli. So he is the Anzac spirit made flesh, Tom. That's why he's so celebrated. And Carlet. Exactly. And we'll come back to the Anzac Spiris and how that was created. And what all this meant for Australian national identity later in this episode?
上面写着：辛普森和他的驴子成为了一个传说，是加里波利所有纯洁、无私和英勇精神的象征。所以，汤姆，他是澳新军团精神的化身。这就是他如此受推崇的原因。卡莱特。没错。我们稍后会在本集中回到澳新军团精神及其创造过程，以及这一切对澳大利亚民族认同意味着什么。
But maybe first we should remind ourselves, what on earth are tens of thousands of Australians and New Zealanders, as well as hundreds of thousands of British and Irish soldiers? and in total almost 80,000 Frenchmen, what are they doing on the coast of Turkey in the spring of 1915? Nothing useful. Well, I mean, I don't want to diss their contribution, but they have been thrown away
但也许我们应该先提醒自己，成千上万的澳大利亚人和新西兰人，以及数十万英国和爱尔兰士兵，总共近8万名法国人，他们在1915年春天在土耳其海岸做什么？没什么有用的事。好吧，我的意思是，我不想贬低他们的贡献，但他们被浪费在
in a very misguided operation. So an operation conceived by the First Lord of the Admiralty, Winston Churchill, to force the Dardanelles, the straits between Europe and Asia, the straits that lead from the Mediterranean to the Black Sea. He thinks he's going to force the straits with his ships,
一场非常误导的行动中。这是一场由第一海军大臣温斯顿·丘吉尔构想的行动，旨在强行通过达达尼尔海峡，即欧洲和亚洲之间的海峡，连接地中海和黑海的海峡。他认为他可以用他的船只强行通过海峡，
is going to bombard Constantinople, knock the Ottomans out of the war. The naval campaign doesn't work. The Asquith government doubles down. They send ground troops to take the European shore of the strait. That's the peninsula of Gallipoli. As we heard last time, they landed at two points. They landed at Anzac Cove on the western side of the peninsula
轰炸君士坦丁堡，将奥斯曼帝国踢出战争。海军战役没有奏效。阿斯奎斯政府加倍投入。他们派遣地面部队占领海峡的欧洲海岸。那就是加里波利半岛。正如我们上次听到的，他们在两个点登陆。他们登陆了半岛西侧的澳新军团湾，
and a Cape Helles on the southern tip. The landing's much bloodier and much more difficult than they imagine. The Turks have been rallied, not least by their young commander Mustafa Kemmel. and the Allies haven't come close to reaching their objectives. And so we left them with night falling on the 25th of April. They're clinging to these fragile footholds, these beachheads. And Sirian Hamilton, the commander, has told them,
以及南端的赫勒斯角。登陆比他们想象的要血腥得多，困难得多。土耳其人被团结起来了，尤其是他们的年轻指挥官穆斯塔法·凯末尔。盟军甚至没有接近他们的目标。所以我们把他们留在了4月25日的夜幕中。他们紧紧抓住这些脆弱的立足点，这些滩头阵地。指挥官伊恩·汉密尔顿告诉他们，
dig yourselves right in and stick it out. Dig, dig, dig, until you're safe. And that's what they're doing. They're digging trenches. Even though it's kind of dust over rock, basically. Exactly. Well, as we'll find out, very shallow and insolubrious trenches. So what now?
挖好战壕，坚持住。挖，挖，挖，直到安全为止。这就是他们正在做的。他们在挖战壕。尽管基本上是在岩石上的尘土中。没错。好吧，正如我们将发现的那样，是非常浅且不卫生的战壕。那么现在呢？
Now remember that just two months ago, Winston Churchill told the War Council, we can make certain of taking Constantinople by the end of March and capturing or destroying all Turkish forces in Europe. Over-optimistic, right? A little bit over-optimistic, because they are not going forwards. Two days after the landings, the Ottomans launched a big attack on the Anzaks, on Anzac Cove. They're trying to drive the Australians and New Zealanders back into the sea. And the Aux perform heroically.
现在记住，就在两个月前，温斯顿·丘吉尔告诉战争委员会，我们可以在3月底前确保占领君士坦丁堡，并俘虏或消灭欧洲所有的土耳其军队。过于乐观了，对吧？确实有点过于乐观，因为他们根本没有前进。登陆两天后，奥斯曼人对澳新军团发动了一次大规模进攻，针对澳新军团湾。他们试图将澳大利亚人和新西兰人赶回海里。澳新军团表现得非常英勇。
They managed to fight them off, but they are definitely not going forward. The British and French further south at Cape Hellies, they do try to go a little bit further forward. On the 28th of April, they made their first attempt to capture the next village in line, which is a village called Crithia. It's about five miles inland from their beaches. This time, the Ottomans hold them off. And by dusk, when the fighting dies down, the British and French have lost about 3,000 men for very little gain. And this basically is the pattern for the next few. months. It's very similar to the other fronts that we've talked about in this series. The Western
他们设法击退了他们，但他们绝对没有前进。在南部的赫勒斯角，英法联军确实试图再向前推进一点。4月28日，他们进行了第一次尝试，试图占领下一个村庄，即克里希亚村。它距离他们的海滩约五英里内陆。这一次，奥斯曼人挡住了他们。到黄昏时分，战斗平息时，英法联军损失了约3000人，却几乎没有取得任何进展。这基本上就是接下来几个月的模式。这与我们在本系列中讨论过的其他战线非常相似。西线
Front in France and Flanders or the Italian Front, where basically you have trenches, you have machine guns, you have barbed wire. If you attack these things, you will probably be killed. Because that's been the pattern throughout the whole war that the Germans, when they invade France, are putting a premium on speed. The Italians, when they try and knock out the Austrian and Empire, they're putting a premium on kind of dash and all of that. And Churchill is part of that continuum, isn't he? And that every attempt to deploy the kind of Napoleonic sense of speed and surprise runs into barbed wire and machine gunfire and slaughter. Completely does.
在法国和法兰德斯，或者意大利战线，基本上你有战壕，有机关枪，有铁丝网。如果你攻击这些东西，你很可能会被杀。因为这是整个战争的模式，德国人在入侵法国时，把速度放在首位。意大利人在试图击垮奥匈帝国时，把冲劲放在首位。丘吉尔也是这种连续性的一部分，不是吗？每一次试图部署那种拿破仑式的速度和突然性的尝试，都会撞上铁丝网、机枪扫射和屠杀。完全是这样。
And basically they're on, I mean, this is what military historians always say about first, we're all generals. They're on a massive learning curve. And it takes some of them longer than others to work it out. So in Gallipoli, just over a week after the first battle of Crithia, the British and French have another go, a second battle. Two days of heavy fighting, and this time they lose almost 7,000 men, and they gain at most half a mile. Because this is the definition of insanity, isn't it?
基本上他们处于，我的意思是，这就是军事历史学家对第一次世界大战将军们的评价。他们处于一个巨大的学习曲线上。有些人比其他人花更长的时间才弄明白。所以在加里波利，在第一次克里希亚战役一周多后，英法联军又进行了一次尝试，第二次战役。两天的激烈战斗，这一次他们损失了近7000人，最多只推进了半英里。因为这就是疯狂的定义，不是吗？
Just doing the same thing over and over again in the expectation that it will change, and of course it never does. But the issue for them, of course, is if you don't do that, what do you do? I mean, they are stuck there. If they continue attacking at this rate, they will a run out of shells and be run out of men. I mean, they'll all be dead by midsummer if they're carrying like this. And this is terrible because Britain needs its forces on the Western Front
一遍又一遍地做同样的事情，却期望结果会改变，当然结果永远不会改变。但对他们来说，问题当然是，如果你不这样做，你该怎么办？我的意思是，他们被困在那里了。如果他们继续以这种速度进攻，他们会：A，耗尽炮弹；B，耗尽兵力。我的意思是，如果他们这样继续下去，到仲夏时他们都会死光的。这太可怕了，因为英国需要其在西线的兵力，
because that's where the war is going to be decided. But on the other hand, the Turks can't get rid of them. They are too well dug in. So when the Turks later in May launch another attempt to push the Australians and New Zealanders into the sea, and they've got twice as many men, the Turks at Anzac Cove, again, defence wins. defense always wins.
因为那是决定战争胜负的地方。但另一方面，土耳其人无法摆脱他们。他们挖得太深了。所以当土耳其人在5月晚些时候发动另一次尝试，试图将澳大利亚人和新西兰人赶入海中时，他们的人数是对方的两倍，在澳新军团湾，防御再次获胜。防御总是获胜。
So this time it's the Anzac machine guns that are ripping through the Turkish attackers. So on the 19th of May, the Anzac's lost fewer than 700 men, but the Turks lost probably 10,000 men. So basically, the Turks have launched this big attack, will drive them into the sea. It has not worked. And as night falls, the no man's land outside the Anzac lines is littered with thousands of dead bodies. And they are, you know, it's hot. It is hot in Turkey in the summer.
所以这一次是澳新军团的机枪在扫射土耳其进攻者。因此，在5月19日，澳新军团损失了不到700人，但土耳其人可能损失了10000人。所以基本上，土耳其人发动了这次大进攻，试图把他们赶入海中。这没有奏效。当夜幕降临时，澳新军团防线外的无人区里到处都是成千上万的尸体。而且，你知道，天气很热。土耳其的夏天很热。
They are rotting in the summer heat. They are covered with flies. There's this dreadful stench of decomposing bodies. And it's a massive health hazard. And this actually is the cue for one of the most celebrated moments of the whole Gallipoli campaign. And this is, it's a little bit like the Christmas truce. So this is a day-long ceasefire, a day-long truce between the Anzaks and the Turks. And the guy who organized this, or one of the main,
它们在夏日的酷暑中腐烂。它们覆盖着苍蝇。有一种可怕的尸体腐烂的恶臭。这是一个巨大的健康隐患。这实际上是整个加里波利战役中最著名的时刻之一的导火索。这有点像圣诞休战。这是一次为期一天的停火，澳新军团和土耳其人之间为期一天的休战。组织这次休战的人，或者主要组织者之一，
organizers were somebody we actually met in a previous First World War series about 1914. And he was a conservative MP and British officer called Aubrey Herbert. And he was an amazing character. I mean, he's basically you, isn't he? He's very similar. I was waiting for this, yeah. He went to Balliol, first class history degree, travelled through the Balkans, speaking every Balkan language, all the other major European languages,
是我们之前在关于1914年的第一次世界大战系列中见过的人。他是一位保守党议员和英国军官，名叫奥布里·赫伯特。他是一个了不起的人物。我的意思是，他基本上就是你，不是吗？他非常相似。我一直在等这个，是的。他去了贝利奥尔学院，获得了历史学一等学位，游历了巴尔干半岛，会说每一种巴尔干语言，以及所有其他主要的欧洲语言，
Turkish, Arabic, Albanian. Yeah. He goes to Yemen dressed as a tramp, which you haven't done. No, I've not done that. But pretty much everything else. He's the model for the kind of the top spy in Green Mantel, which we talked about in the previous episode. Sandia Abuthnotts. And also, I hadn't twigged this.
土耳其语、阿拉伯语、阿尔巴尼亚语。是的。他打扮成流浪汉去了也门，你还没做过。不，我没做过。但除此之外几乎都做了。他是我们在上一集中讨论过的《绿斗篷》中那种顶级间谍的原型。桑迪·阿巴斯诺特。而且，我之前没注意到这一点。
He's the younger stepbrother of the Lord Knavan, who after the war will discover Tutankarman. Oh, I did not know that. Oh, that's interesting. So he's born at Highclair, which is downtown abbey. So it all links. He's just an absolutely amazing man. We had a description of him at the Battle of Mons being captured by. Germans. He ended up escaping from the Germans. Of course. Because he speaks Turkish and because
他是卡纳冯勋爵同母异父的弟弟，卡纳冯勋爵在战后发现了图坦卡蒙墓。哦，我不知道。哦，那很有趣。所以他出生在海克利尔，也就是《唐顿庄园》。所以这一切都联系在一起了。他真是一个绝对了不起的人。我们曾描述过他在蒙斯战役中被德国人俘虏。他最终从德国人手中逃脱了。当然。因为他会说土耳其语，而且因为
he's a master of tongues in the Balkans. He is you. He wangles the job as a staff officer and interpreter for the Australian commander, General Birdwood. So like me, he's very fond of Australians and Australia. So, and also, you know, he gets somewhere with Turks, as I do. So an Australophile Turkophile Balkan old hand who went to Balliol. I mean, this is just spooky. It's sound galley, isn't it? So he takes the lead in the negotiations with Mustafa Kemmel, and they'll have a formal ceasefire on the 24th of May so they can all bury their dead. And both of them sent out, the Turks and the Anzac sent out groups with white armbands. They'd marked a line down the middle of no man's land.
他是巴尔干半岛的语言大师。他就是你。他设法谋得了一个职位，担任澳大利亚指挥官伯德伍德将军的参谋和翻译。所以像我一样，他非常喜欢澳大利亚人和澳大利亚。而且，你知道，他在土耳其人那里也很有办法，就像我一样。所以一个去过贝利奥尔学院的、热爱澳大利亚、热爱土耳其、精通巴尔干半岛的老手。我的意思是，这真是太诡异了。这听起来很像加里波利，不是吗？所以他在与穆斯塔法·凯末尔的谈判中发挥了主导作用，他们将在5月24日进行正式停火，以便他们都能埋葬死者。双方，土耳其人和澳新军团都派出了戴着白色臂章的小组。他们在无人区中间划了一条线。
And there's a lovely description from Corporal Charles Livingston of the New South Wales Light Horse. He says, we stood together some 12 feet apart, quite friendly, exchanging coins and other articles. A Turk gave me a beautiful Sultan's guard belt buckle made of brass with a silver star and crescent embossed with the Sultan's scroll in Arabic. All I had to give him in exchange were a few coins. That's poor from the Australians. Our troops carried the dead Turkish bodies over the dividing line
有一段来自新南威尔士轻骑兵查尔斯·利文斯顿下士的精彩描述。他说，我们站在一起，相距约12英尺，非常友好，交换硬币和其他物品。一个土耳其人给了我一个漂亮的苏丹卫队腰带扣，是黄铜做的，上面浮雕着银色的星月，还有阿拉伯文的苏丹卷轴。我能给他的交换物只有几枚硬币。澳大利亚人表现得太差了。我们的部队把土耳其死者的尸体抬过分界线，
and the Turkish troops did the same for our dead. So that's nice. Now people may be thinking, while they're bearing the bodies, what are the other Australians doing? Are they having a Barbie? We know how Australians behave. This is Private Victor Lederl,
土耳其部队也为我们的死者做了同样的事。这很好。现在人们可能会想，当他们埋葬尸体时，其他澳大利亚人在做什么？他们在开烧烤派对吗？我们知道澳大利亚人的行为方式。这是维克多·莱德尔列兵，
wrote in a letter. Everybody's taking advantage of the armistice to do anything they want to do out of cover, a large number of down bathing. And you'd think today was Cup Day down at one of our seaside beaches. So basically, you'll just go on to the beach. So brilliant. So brilliant. But then as dusk falls, the Turks start firing again, as Corporal Livingston says,
在信中写道。每个人都利用停火机会在掩体外做任何他们想做的事，很多人在游泳。你会以为今天是我们海滨海滩的杯赛日。所以基本上，他们只是去海滩。太棒了。太棒了。但当黄昏降临时，土耳其人又开始开火了，正如利文斯顿下士所说，
we were once again enemies. And indeed they are. So the similarity there with the Western Front and the Christmas truce, the similarities go beyond the ceasefire, because actually what's happened now is the trenches have become institutionalized as they were in France and Flanders. So they've dug front lines, they've dug reserve lines, they've dug communications trenches. And when you look at the soldiers' accounts from Gallipoli, there are some things that are very familiar. So there's the thud of the guns.
我们再次成为了敌人。确实如此。所以那里与西线和圣诞休战的相似之处，不仅仅在于停火，因为实际上现在发生的事情是战壕已经制度化了，就像在法国和法兰德斯一样。所以他们挖了前线，挖了预备线，挖了交通壕。当你查看加里波利士兵的记录时，有些事情是非常熟悉的。比如炮火的沉闷声。
The crump, I believe you are. You are required to say crumb. I knew you were going to say crump at that point. There's the threat of sniper fire. There's the knowledge that, you know, you poke your head up at the wrong moment. and you're dead, all of that. But veterans consistently said, if they did both, they said Gallipoli was worse than the Western Front.
“砰”的一声，我相信你。你被要求说“砰”。我就知道你会在那个时候说“砰”。有狙击手火力的威胁。有那种你知道的，你在错误的时间探出头，你就会死，所有这些。但老兵们一致表示，如果他们两者都经历过，他们说加里波利比西线更糟糕。
The terrain is different, so the trenches are much shallower. The dugouts are much more primitive. The temperatures are more extreme, so hot in the summer, so cold in the winter, and everything is covered. You know, you're close to the sea, there's a sea wind, everything is covered with this layer of dust. Because of the terrain, there is a constant, problem of burying the dead.
地形不同，所以战壕浅得多。防空洞原始得多。温度更极端，夏天太热，冬天太冷，而且一切都被覆盖了。你知道，你靠近大海，有海风，一切都被覆盖着一层灰尘。由于地形原因，埋葬死者是一个持续的问题。
You can't, basically, it's very difficult to do. And because of snipers, you can't go and get bodies easily. So there's only that one day of a ceasefire, and then there aren't any more, or there's no formal ones. So the bodies by and large just lie there, rotting on the parapets or rotting in no man's land. Asquith's son, Arthur, who was called Ock. He was there at Gallipoli. And he wrote later, he said, bodies lay everywhere, unburied and half buried.
你基本上无法做到，这非常困难。而且因为有狙击手，你不能轻易去取尸体。所以只有那一天停火，然后就没有了，或者没有正式的停火。所以尸体大体上就躺在那里，在胸墙上腐烂，或者在无人区腐烂。阿斯奎斯的儿子亚瑟，被称为“奥克”。他在加里波利。他后来写道，他说，尸体到处都是，未埋葬或半埋葬。
The weather was sweltering, the stench overwhelming, and many of our officers and men were sick again and again. I mean, they're vomiting because of the smell. Even more than on the western front, the bodies attract colossal quantities of flies. This is a private, looking back. The whole of the side of the trench used to be one black swarming mass. Anything you open, like a tin of bully beef, would be swarming with flies.
天气闷热，恶臭难闻，我们的许多军官和士兵一次又一次地生病。我的意思是，他们因为气味而呕吐。比在西线更严重的是，尸体吸引了大量的苍蝇。这是一个列兵的回忆。整个战壕的一侧曾经是一团黑压压的、蠕动的苍蝇。你打开的任何东西，比如一罐咸牛肉，都会爬满苍蝇。
They were all around your mouth, on any cuts or sores that you got, which then turned septic, and immediately you bared any part of your. your body, you were smothered. It's the worst Mediterranean beach holiday ever. It is. It is. And it's actually, I mean, here's another thing. There is undoubtedly an aspect of misguided and unfortunate Mediterranean beach holidays. It's the issue of toilets. And it may seem odd to talk about this, but basically this is one thing that veterans always mentioned. They said, you know, when you look back at Gallipoli, of course, it's the Turks and there's machine guns and stuff,
它们就在你的嘴边，在你身上的任何伤口或溃疡上，然后溃疡就会化脓，一旦你露出身体的任何部位，你就会被覆盖。这是有史以来最糟糕的地中海海滩度假。确实是。确实是。而且实际上，我的意思是，这里还有一件事。毫无疑问，这有误导和不幸的地中海海滩度假的成分。那就是厕所问题。谈论这个似乎很奇怪，但基本上这是老兵们总是提到的事情。他们说，你知道，当你回顾加里波利时，当然，有土耳其人，有机关枪之类的，
but the toilet thing is huge. Because on the Western front, there's wood. There is spruce. There is space. There are supplies of disinfectants and whatnot. At Gallipoli, there are basically no toilet facilities worthy of the name and they don't have any toilet paper. So men would use letters from home. I mean, that must have been awful for them to do because the letters aren't so much to them. But then when they ran out of letters from home, they use their bare hands to wipe themselves. And then they would wipe their hands in the dirt or then wipe them on their clothes. And as a result of this, they're absolutely ravaged with dysentery. and this seems an odd thing again to talk about so much on a history podcast,
但厕所问题非常严重。因为在西线上，有木头。有云杉。有空间。有消毒剂之类的供应。在加里波利，基本上没有像样的厕所设施，而且他们没有任何卫生纸。所以士兵们会用家里的信件。我的意思是，这对他们来说一定很糟糕，因为信件对他们来说意义重大。但当他们用完了家里的信件，他们就用赤手擦拭自己。然后他们会把手擦在泥土里，或者擦在衣服上。结果，他们完全被痢疾折磨。这在历史播客中谈论这么多似乎又是一件奇怪的事情，
but it's a central element of the kind of the Gallipoli experience. Well, I mean, dysentery, you could do an entire history of the world in terms of dysentery. Most people who ever died died of diarrhea. Because we did that series with Carl Harper, and he made exactly this point. Yeah, that blew my mind that point. I've bored people with it ever since. There's so many people in history died of diarrhea. I mean, soldiers who survived Gallipoli said afterwards, you know, this was the defining aspect of the experience, that we would literally, and you would be sitting there with really hard men who were in tears sobbing with the kind of pain and humiliation. To quote one, we wept not because we were frightened, but because we were so dirty. So a good example of somebody who might seem the incarnation of kind of buttoned up dignity, and that's Clement Attlee, the future Labour, British Labour Prime Minister, a captain and a captain and a
但它是加里波利体验的核心要素。好吧，我的意思是，痢疾，你可以写一部关于痢疾的世界史。大多数死过的人都是死于腹泻。因为我们和卡尔·哈珀做了那个系列，他正是指出了这一点。是的，那一点让我大开眼界。从那以后我一直用它来烦别人。历史上死于腹泻的人太多了。我的意思是，在加里波利幸存下来的士兵事后说，你知道，这是这种体验的决定性方面，我们真的会，你会坐在那里，和那些非常坚强的男人在一起，他们泪流满面，因为那种痛苦和羞辱而啜泣。引用其中一个人的话，我们哭泣不是因为我们害怕，而是因为我们太脏了。所以一个很好的例子，一个看起来像是那种拘谨尊严化身的人，那就是克莱门特·艾德礼，未来的英国工党首相，一名上尉，在
South Lancashires he got dysentery at Cape Hellies he fainted because he was so weak from the dysentery he was taken back to the beach and invalided out to Malta and then incredibly I mean great credit to Attlee he was so keen to rejoin his comrades that he got himself sent back to Gallipoli and came back in the autumn he just was very laconic as was his way he said yes I had dysentery and then he just changed the subject but actually some of the stories are horrendous and this is one story or was stuck in my mind since I first read it. Ordinary seaman Joe Murray who was in the Royal Naval Division, and it goes
南兰开夏郡团，他在赫勒斯角得了痢疾，他因为痢疾虚弱而晕倒，被送回海滩，并被遣送回马耳他，然后令人难以置信的是，我的意思是，艾德礼非常值得称赞，他非常渴望回到战友身边，以至于他设法让自己被送回加里波利，并在秋天回来了。他就像他的风格一样非常简洁，他说，是的，我得了痢疾，然后他就换了话题。但实际上有些故事是可怕的，这是一个自从我第一次读到它就一直萦绕在我心头的故事。普通海员乔·默里，他在皇家海军师，故事是
as follows. He says a couple of weeks before getting it, my old pal was as smart and upright as a guardsman. Yet after about ten days it was dreadful to see him crawling about, his trousers around his feet, his shirt all soiled, everything was soiled. He couldn't even walk. So I took him by one
这样的。他说，在得病前几周，我的老伙计像卫兵一样聪明挺拔。然而大约十天后，看到他爬来爬去真是太可怕了，他的裤子挂在脚踝上，衬衫全脏了，一切都脏了。他甚至不能走路。所以我抓住他的一只
arm and another pal got hold of him by another and we dragged him to the latrine. We tried to keep the flies off him and to turn him round to put his backside towards the trench. But he's simply rolled into this foot-wide trench, half-sideways, head-first into the slime. We couldn't pull him out. We didn't have enough strength, and he couldn't help himself at all. We did eventually get him out, but he was dead. He had drowned in his own excrement.
胳膊，另一个伙伴抓住他的另一只，我们把他拖到厕所。我们试图把苍蝇赶走，并把他转过来，让他的屁股对着战壕。但他只是滚进了这个一英尺宽的战壕里，半侧着身子，头朝下掉进了污泥里。我们无法把他拉出来。我们没有足够的力气，而他自己根本帮不上忙。我们最终确实把他拉了出来，但他已经死了。他淹死在自己的排泄物里。
I mean, there are lots of stories like this. Not a good way to... It's not Achilles, isn't it? It's not a good way to die. It's not even Rupert Brooke. So, loads of English language accounts, actually in English language accounts, the Turks have barely mentioned, We know that their conditions were really grim as well. Mustafa Kemmel wrote to his Italian mistress, Our life here is truly hellish. But then he added,
我的意思是，有很多这样的故事。不是一个好的方式去……这不是阿喀琉斯，不是吗？这不是一个好的死法。甚至不是鲁珀特·布鲁克。所以，大量的英语记录，实际上在英语记录中，土耳其人几乎没有被提及，我们知道他们的条件也非常严峻。穆斯塔法·凯末尔写信给他的意大利情妇，我们在这里的生活真是地狱。但他接着补充说，
Fortunately, my soldiers are very brave and they are tougher than the enemy. I mean, that sentence would have astounded the British planners before the campaign because they were convinced the Turks would run away. And Mustafa Kemmel then has this fantastic line. He says to his mistress, The great thing about my soldiers is so many of them are very devout Muslims. So they're not really frightened of death. They know they will, quote, go straight to heaven.
幸运的是，我的士兵非常勇敢，他们比敌人更坚强。我的意思是，那句话会让英国策划者在战役前感到震惊，因为他们确信土耳其人会逃跑。然后穆斯塔法·凯末尔说了这句精彩的话。他告诉他的情妇，我的士兵最棒的地方在于他们中有许多是非常虔诚的穆斯林。所以他们并不真正害怕死亡。他们知道他们会，引用，直接去天堂。
There the Hurries, God's most beautiful women, will meet them and will satisfy their desires for all eternity. What great happiness! I don't think he's being ironic there. He is being ironic, of course, because Mustafa Kemmel had a very semi-detached relationship with his own fate. To put it mildly. Exactly. But he's clearly been quite wry about this. Anyway, this is the general situation at Gallipoli.
在那里，胡里，上帝最美丽的女人，会迎接他们，并满足他们永恒的欲望。多么大的幸福！我不认为他在那里是讽刺的。当然，他是讽刺的，因为穆斯塔法·凯末尔对他自己的命运有一种非常超然的关系。说得委婉一点。没错。但他显然对此相当苦涩。总之，这就是加里波利的总体情况。
It's a total stalemate, flies everywhere, excrement everywhere. It is horrendous. Now, what of the man who is responsible for all the... this, who came up with this great scheme, Winston Churchill. Back in London, Churchill is absolutely unrepentant. He's still telling everybody that the campaign can be won. But the newspapers are beginning to turn against him. So, for example, the Tory Morning Post calls him a danger to the country. And that is because his first sea lord, Jackie Fisher, is now actively briefing against him and leaking bad news about Gallipoli and basically telling everyone that Churchill's got to go.
这是一个彻底的僵局，到处都是苍蝇，到处都是排泄物。这太可怕了。现在，那个对这一切负责的人，那个想出这个伟大计划的人，温斯顿·丘吉尔，怎么样了？回到伦敦，丘吉尔绝对是不知悔改的。他仍然告诉每个人这场战役是可以赢的。但报纸开始反对他了。所以，例如，保守党的《晨邮报》称他为国家的危险。这是因为他的第一海务大臣杰基·费舍尔现在正在积极地针对他进行简报，泄露关于加里波利的坏消息，并基本上告诉每个人丘吉尔必须走人。
So he's the kind of small guy who's yellow. He's yellow, he likes dancing, likes church, but he's also too old, and is very disputatious and difficult. Now, also, some of the people in the liberal government are beginning to lose faith in Churchill. So Lloyd George told Margo Asquith at the beginning of May, Churchill has not merely bad judgment, he has none. His Dardanelles expedition gave the Turk a frightfully long start. He got us at war with the Turk, which he need never have done. And so a few days after that, you have a... a succession of events which rock the Liberal government to put Churchill's own place in great
所以他就是那种胆小的矮个子。他胆小，喜欢跳舞，喜欢教堂，但他年纪也太大了，而且非常爱争论和难以相处。现在，自由党政府中的一些人也开始对丘吉尔失去信心。所以劳埃德·乔治在5月初告诉玛戈·阿斯奎斯，丘吉尔不仅判断力差，他根本没有判断力。他的达达尼尔远征给了土耳其人一个可怕的长期优势。他让我们与土耳其人开战，而这本是不必要的。所以在那之后几天，发生了一系列事件，动摇了自由党政府，使丘吉尔自己的地位处于极大的
jeopardy. So the first of all, we already described her Asquith was distracted through all this because of his infatuation with Venetia Stanley. On the 11th of May, Venetia Stanley tells Asquith that she's going to marry one of his ministers, Edwin Montague. And Asquith is absolutely devastated. He is heartbroken. He is a wreck of a man once she's told him. this. It's almost as bad as suffering dysentery on an exposed hill in Gallipoli. Asquith's the real victim and all this stuff. Yeah, he really is. And that will run throughout the rest of this episode, that Asquith's basically a shadow of a man now. The very next day, the 12th of May, Jackie Fisher makes his seventh attempt to resign. And again, they have to persuade
危险之中。所以首先，我们已经描述过阿斯奎斯因为对维尼蒂亚·斯坦利的迷恋而在这期间分心。5月11日，维尼蒂亚·斯坦利告诉阿斯奎斯她要嫁给他的部长之一，埃德温·蒙塔古。阿斯奎斯绝对崩溃了。他心碎了。她告诉他这件事后，他成了一个废人。这几乎和在加里波利暴露的山坡上患痢疾一样糟糕。阿斯奎斯是这一切中真正的受害者。是的，他确实是。这将贯穿本集的其余部分，阿斯奎斯现在基本上是一个人的影子。就在第二天，5月12日，杰基·费舍尔第七次尝试辞职。他们又不得不说服
him not to. And the newspapers are now full of rumours that the Asquith government, which doesn't have an overall majority, and they haven't had one, since the beginning of the war, and basically there'd been a sort of political truce since the beginning of the war, but now the conservatives are running out of patients. The rumours that the Asweth government is going to collapse. Two days after this, on the 14th of May, the Times publishes this, I mean, there's no other word but a bombshell, bombshell report, that the British troops on the Western Front are running out of high explosive shells, and that this is because of government incompetence.
他不要辞职。报纸现在充斥着谣言，称阿斯奎斯政府，它没有绝对多数，而且自战争开始以来就没有多数，基本上自战争开始以来就有一种政治休战，但现在保守党已经失去了耐心。谣言称阿斯奎斯政府即将垮台。两天后，5月14日，《泰晤士报》发表了这篇，我的意思是，除了“重磅炸弹”没有别的词，重磅炸弹报道，称西线的英军正在耗尽高爆炮弹，这是因为政府的无能。
And again, rather like the Jackie Fisher stories, this is the result of leaks and briefings from within the government. So it's come particularly from Sir John French, the commander on the Western Front, who's in cahoots. Is it true? Yes, they were running out of shells. Everyone was running out of shells. I don't think it was that Britain was peculiar incompetent. Every combatant by the spring of summer of 1915 is basically running out of shells because they've used all their pre-war supplies. But in Britain, this is used as a weapon to expose what the critics of the government see as its kind of lassitude.
同样，就像杰基·费舍尔的故事一样，这是政府内部泄密和简报的结果。所以它特别来自西线指挥官约翰·弗伦奇爵士，他与人勾结。这是真的吗？是的，他们的炮弹快用完了。每个人的炮弹都快用完了。我不认为英国特别无能。到1915年春夏，每个参战国基本上都在耗尽炮弹，因为他们用光了战前的所有储备。但在英国，这被用作一种武器，来揭露政府批评者所认为的某种懒散。
And Asquith is reading the classics and having his hair cut and going to society parties. And they think he should be chairing munitions meetings and being more serious. So the same day the Shell story breaks, the war council meets in what Churchill later called a sulfurous atmosphere. And they discuss, are we going to pull out of Gallipoli? And Lord Kitchener, the war secretary, repeats his point. He says, no, we cannot pull out even now. It will destroy Britain's prestige in the Muslim world. It will lose us the possible support of the Balkan neutrals, people like Romania, Bulgaria, whoever.
阿斯奎斯在读经典著作，理发，参加社交聚会。他们认为他应该主持军火会议，表现得更严肃。就在炮弹故事爆发的同一天，战争委员会在丘吉尔后来所说的“硫磺味”气氛中开会。他们讨论，我们要撤出加里波利吗？战争大臣基奇纳勋爵重复了他的观点。他说，不，即使现在我们也不能撤出。这会摧毁英国在穆斯林世界的声望。这会让我们失去巴尔干半岛中立国的可能支持，比如罗马尼亚、保加利亚，无论谁。
We just have to keep going. To what end? Well, this is the point. I mean, don't ask me, I'm not Lord Kitchener. I put it to you. This is nonsense. It is nonsense. I wouldn't have gone in the first place.
我们必须坚持下去。为了什么目的？好吧，这就是重点。我的意思是，别问我，我不是基奇纳勋爵。我向你提出。这是胡说八道。这是胡说八道。我一开始就不会进去。
Let me be absolutely clear. I'm going to put it on the right. I do not have as distinguished a military record as Lord Kitchener. Yeah. But it seems to me madness. Because even if you push the Turks, if you, the Turk, sorry, off Gallipoli, so what? Yeah, well, exactly, that's the whole point.
让我说得绝对清楚。我要把它放在右边。我没有像基奇纳勋爵那样杰出的军事记录。是的。但这在我看来是疯狂的。因为即使你把土耳其人，如果你，土耳其人，抱歉，赶出加里波利，那又怎样？是的，好吧，没错，这就是重点。
So what? Then you still got that. I don't forget, this is a side quest. It's not even the main quest. It's mad. It is mad. So the next day, 15th of May, Fisher finally does resign and in pleasingly bizarre and ludicrous circumstances. He sends a resignation letter to Ascuit. He says, I was against Gallipoli from the start.
那又怎样？那你还是有那个。别忘了，这是一个支线任务。它甚至不是主线任务。这太疯狂了。这太疯狂了。所以第二天，5月15日，费舍尔终于辞职了，而且是在令人愉快的离奇和荒谬的情况下。他给阿斯奎斯发了一封辞职信。他说，我从一开始就反对加里波利。
It's mad. You've made fools of yourselves. I'm off. And then he vanishes. He leaves the ambrality and disappears. And some historians think because he was very religious, he went to pray at Westminster Abbey, whatever it takes. Anyway, Asquith sends men after him to try to persuade him out of resigning. I mean, again, it's rather like the Kitchener. They've employed these sort of old war horses who are useless. But then they don't want them to resign because it would look really bad. the sort of PR would be really bad. Yeah. So it's like Kitchner doesn't want to withdraw from Glippley because it would look bad.
这太疯狂了。你们让自己成了傻瓜。我走了。然后他就消失了。他离开了海军部，不见了。一些历史学家认为，因为他非常虔诚，他去威斯敏斯特教堂祈祷了，无论需要什么。总之，阿斯奎斯派人去追他，试图说服他不要辞职。我的意思是，这又有点像基奇纳。他们雇佣了这些无用的老战马。但他们又不想让他们辞职，因为那看起来会很糟糕，那种公关会很糟糕。是的。所以就像基奇纳不想从加里波利撤军，因为那看起来会很糟糕。
They don't want to attack Fisher because that would look bad. So they just nail to these mad appointments and strategies. Exactly. So Asquith sends men to track. They track Fisher down at the Charing Cross Hotel. And they hand him a letter from Asquith. And Asquith commands him to return to his post in the name of the king, which is a great thing to write. Fisher says, well, I'll only return on the following conditions,
他们不想攻击费舍尔，因为那看起来会很糟糕。所以他们只是坚持这些疯狂的任命和策略。没错。所以阿斯奎斯派人去追踪。他们在查令十字车站酒店找到了费舍尔。他们递给他一封阿斯奎斯的信。阿斯奎斯以国王的名义命令他回到岗位，这真是一件伟大的事情。费舍尔说，好吧，我只会在以下条件下回来，
you will withdraw from the Dardanelles and you will sack Churchill, quote, a bigger danger than the Germans. And Asquith says, oh, no, no, that's too much. And Asquith then says to the king, Fisher's gone mad, I'm going to accept Fisher's resignation. But this turns out to be the trigger for the fall of the government. Because as we said, until now there's been a truce between the two parties, but the Tory leader, Bono Law, he says to Ashton, Look, fish are going, my backbenchers, the ordinary Tories will no longer accept Churchill at the Admiralty.
你将从达达尼尔撤军，你将解雇丘吉尔，引用，“比德国人更大的危险”。阿斯奎斯说，哦，不，不，那太过分了。然后阿斯奎斯对国王说，费舍尔疯了，我要接受费舍尔的辞职。但这成了政府倒台的导火索。因为正如我们所说，直到现在两党之间一直有休战，但保守党领袖博纳·劳对阿斯奎斯说，看，费舍尔走了，我的后座议员，普通的保守党人将不再接受丘吉尔留在海军部。
And so the next few days in Westminster were dominated by these serpentine machinations. It's got a very long story short. Asquith, Lloyd George and Bono-Law, the Tory leader, agreed to form a coalition government. And Asquith can stay on as Prime Minister, but he has to make two sacrifices. One of them, he has to sack one of his closest friends, Lord Haldane, the man who had modernised Britain's army before the war, who's now Lord Chancellor, Haldane has been smeared by the press as pro-German
接下来的几天里，威斯敏斯特被这些错综复杂的阴谋所笼罩。长话短说，阿斯奎斯、劳合·乔治和保守党领袖博纳·劳同意组建联合政府。阿斯奎斯可以留任首相，但他必须做出两个牺牲。其中之一是，他必须解雇他最亲密的朋友之一——霍尔丹勋爵，这位战前曾对英国军队进行现代化改造、现任大法官的人，却被媒体抹黑为亲德派。
because he had the effrontery to have studied philosophy at the University of Göttingen. Can't trust a man who studied philosophy in Germany. So basically, this is a terrible... I mean, I'm a big Asgwick fan, but this is very, very bad behaviour from Asgweth. Asgweth Sax, one of his closest friends... No greater love hath a man
因为他竟然有胆量在哥廷根大学学习哲学。不能信任一个在德国学哲学的人。所以基本上，这太糟糕了……我是说，我是阿斯奎斯的忠实粉丝，但阿斯奎斯的这种行为实在是非常、非常恶劣。阿斯奎斯解雇了他最亲密的朋友之一……人为朋友舍命，人的爱心没有比这个大的。
than to lay down his life for a friend. Yeah. And then the Tories say, we want to get rid of Churchill. We hate Churchill. Churchill used to be one of us. He's a traitor. He's a snake.
是啊。然后保守党说，我们要除掉丘吉尔。我们讨厌丘吉尔。丘吉尔曾经是我们的一员。他是个叛徒。他是个阴险小人。
He goes around making mad speeches. He's a braggot. He's totally unreliable and mad. Get rid. And the funny thing is, you know, Churchill obviously, you know, the greatest Britain, whatever.
他到处发表疯狂的演讲。他是个吹牛大王。他完全不可靠，是个疯子。除掉他。有趣的是，你知道，丘吉尔显然是，你知道，最伟大的英国人，诸如此类。
He is at this point unbelievably unpopular across the political spectrum. So Asquith, when he's debating this, with his wife Margo, he said, Churchill is by far the most disliked man in my cabinet by his colleagues. Oh, he's intolerable, noisy, long-winded and full of perforations.
但在这一点上，他在整个政治光谱中都极其不受欢迎。所以阿斯奎斯在和他的妻子玛戈讨论这件事时说，丘吉尔是他内阁中同事们最讨厌的人。哦，他令人无法忍受，吵闹，冗长乏味，满口胡言。
Lloyd George said to his mistress, this is Churchill's own fault. He saw in the war the chance for glory for himself, and he's entered on a risky campaign without caring a straw for the misery and hardship that it would bring to thousands. I mean, Lord George is quite right about that, by the way. George V wrote in his diary. He said it'd be brilliant to get rid of Churchill from the average,
劳合·乔治对他的情妇说，这是丘吉尔自找的。他在战争中看到了为自己博取名声的机会，他发动了一场冒险的战役，却根本不在乎这会给成千上万的人带来怎样的苦难和艰辛。顺便说一句，劳合·乔治对此说得很对。乔治五世在日记中写道。他说，把丘吉尔从海军部赶走真是太棒了，
Admiralty, he is the real danger. So basically the deal is they'll get rid of Churchill. They'll also get rid of Fisher, all of this. Asgith will stay on as Prime Minister of a coalition government. I mean, presumably now they've got rid of Churchill. That's brilliant. They can say it's all been a disaster, pin the blame on him, and, you know, cut your losses. This is the insane thing, right?
他是真正的危险。所以基本上交易就是他们会除掉丘吉尔。他们也会除掉费舍尔，所有这些人。阿斯奎斯将继续担任联合政府的首相。我的意思是，大概现在他们已经除掉了丘吉尔。这太棒了。他们可以说这一切都是一场灾难，把责任推到他身上，然后，你知道，止损。这才是最疯狂的地方，对吧？
This is absolutely bonkers. The same day as all this is going on the 17th of May, Sir Ian Hamilton sends a cable to the war office from the Aegean. He says, we've tried to break out of our beachheads. The Turks have resisted much more stubbornly than we expected. The troops have done well, but they are absolutely exhausted. We need, if you're going to keep us here, we absolutely need reinforcing as soon as possible. But because of the political crisis, no one answers. And in fact, they don't answer for weeks.
这简直是疯了。就在这一切发生的同一天，即5月17日，伊恩·汉密尔顿爵士从爱琴海向陆军部发了一份电报。他说，我们试图突破我们的滩头阵地。土耳其人的抵抗比我们预期的要顽强得多。部队表现得很好，但他们已经精疲力竭了。我们需要，如果你打算让我们留在这里，我们绝对需要尽快增援。但由于政治危机，没有人回应。事实上，他们几周都没有回应。
The War Council doesn't meet again until the 7th of June, which is almost a month later. and then if they do decide to send reinforcements, it would take weeks to get them there. So basically for the next six weeks, these poor blocs at Gallipoli with dysentery are stuck in their trenches, the Turks shooting at them, and they're waiting to find out what happens at Westminster
战争委员会直到6月7日才再次开会，那已经是近一个月后了。而且即使他们决定派遣增援部队，也需要几周时间才能到达。所以基本上在接下来的六周里，加里波利的这些可怜的家伙们患着痢疾，被困在战壕里，土耳其人向他们射击，他们等着看威斯敏斯特会发生什么，
for the politicians to sort themselves out and to get their act together. And what makes that worse is that Churchill won't go? So he's still fighting to cling on to office. He drafts a public letter, saying none of this is his fault, it's all 50s. vicious fault. He has a massive strop and a tantrum with Lord George, had once
等着政客们解决自己的问题，理清头绪。更糟糕的是，丘吉尔不肯走？所以他还在为保住职位而挣扎。他起草了一封公开信，说这一切都不是他的错，全是费舍尔的错。他跟劳合·乔治大发雷霆，而劳合·乔治曾经
been one of his closest friends. Churchill's so self-regarding. You don't care what becomes of me. You don't care for my personal reputation. Lord George says, no, I don't. I only care about winning the war. And then this brilliant thing. He gets Clemmy to write Ask With a letter.
是他最亲密的朋友之一。丘吉尔太自私了。你不关心我会怎样。你不关心我的个人名誉。劳合·乔治说，不，我不关心。我只关心赢得战争。然后是这件绝妙的事。他让克莱米写了一封信给阿斯奎斯。
You know, tear-stained letter. Why would you part with Winston? You will be committing an act of weakness. Your coalition government will be, you know, rubbish and all this kind of thing. Asquith, there's some excellent cat in us now. Asquith shows this letter to his wife, Margo. And Margo is, what's your expression? A baggage. And Margo's a massive baggage. She is like the world's most, she makes Virginia Woolf look democratic and open-minded. So a baggage, not a spitfire. She's both a baggage and a spitfire. She's... The worst kind of baggage. Yeah,
你知道，泪流满面的信。你为什么要和温斯顿分道扬镳？你这是在表现软弱。你的联合政府会是，你知道，垃圾之类的东西。阿斯奎斯，现在有一些出色的猫腻。阿斯奎斯把这封信给他的妻子玛戈看。玛戈是，你的表达是什么？一个泼妇。玛戈是个十足的泼妇。她就像世界上最，她让弗吉尼亚·伍尔夫看起来都显得民主和开明。所以是个泼妇，不是个悍妇。她既是泼妇又是悍妇。她是……最糟糕的那种泼妇。是的，
and the worst kind of spitfire. Asclus shows Marco this letter from Clementine Churchill. And Marco says, It shows the soul of a servant. That touch of black male and insolence and the revelation of black ingratitude and want of affection justifies everything I've thought of this shallow couple. And Asquist says, basically, that's going a bit far, isn't it? It's the letter of her wife. And Margot says, a fishwife, you mean?
也是最糟糕的那种悍妇。阿斯奎斯给玛戈看了克莱门汀·丘吉尔的这封信。玛戈说，这显露出仆人的灵魂。那种勒索和傲慢的意味，以及那种黑色的忘恩负义和缺乏感情的流露，证明了我对这对浅薄夫妇的所有看法都是对的。阿斯奎斯说，基本上，这有点过分了吧？这是他妻子的信。玛戈说，你是说鱼贩婆吗？
Yeah, she is a bit far, and a baggage. No question. Anyway, Churchill's basically dragged out of the Admiralty on the 25th of May. is fobbed off with a kind of non-job, Chancellor of the Duchy of Lancaster. Most offices in the Navy were delighted that Churchill had gone.
是的，她确实有点过分，而且是个泼妇。毫无疑问。总之，丘吉尔基本上在5月25日被拖出了海军部。被一个闲职打发了，兰开斯特公爵领地大臣。海军里大多数官员都对丘吉尔的离开感到高兴。
Admiral Jellico wrote to Fisher, We owe you a debt of gratitude for having saved the Navy from a continuance in office of Mr. Churchill. Admiral Beattie, the Navy breathes freer now that it is rid of the succorpus Churchill.
杰利科海军上将写信给费舍尔说，我们欠你一份感激之情，因为你把海军从丘吉尔先生的继续任职中拯救了出来。贝蒂海军上将说，海军现在摆脱了丘吉尔这个吸血鬼，呼吸得更顺畅了。
Churchill has gutted. I mean, Churchill goes around saying to everybody, you know, I'm finished, I've been totally humiliated and all this. and Clemy said later on to one of his biographers, I thought he would never get over the Dardanelles. I thought he would die of grief.
丘吉尔被掏空了。我的意思是，丘吉尔到处对每个人说，你知道，我完了，我受到了彻底的羞辱等等。克莱米后来对他的传记作者之一说，我以为他永远无法从达达尼尔海峡的阴影中走出来。我以为他会因悲伤而死。
And there were some people who thought that Churchill might actually take his own life, that he was so crushed and depressed by his public humiliation. But he signs up and goes off and fights. He does indeed. And we'll just, we'll come to that a little bit later. Now, Callipoli, they're still waiting for news. They launch a third battle of Crithia under Sir Eilmer. Hunter Western with his excellent mustache.
有些人甚至认为丘吉尔可能会真的自杀，因为他被公众的羞辱压得喘不过气来，陷入了抑郁。但他还是报名参战了。他确实去了。我们稍后再谈这个。现在，加里波利，他们还在等待消息。他们在埃尔默·亨特-韦斯顿爵士的指挥下发动了第三次克里西亚战役，他留着那撇出色的胡子。
Classic kind of first world war behavior, bombardment, over the top. They get about 200 yards and then... And then basically, yeah, the Turks kill them all. They lose about 6,000 men. The Australian writer Les Carlian said that General Hunter Western, he was one of the Great Wars spectacular incompetence. He threw away men the way that other men tossed away, socks. And is that fair?
典型的第一次世界大战式的行为，炮击，冲锋。他们推进了大约200码，然后……然后基本上，是的，土耳其人杀光了他们。他们损失了大约6000人。澳大利亚作家莱斯·卡利安说，亨特-韦斯顿将军是第一次世界大战中壮观的无能者之一。他丢弃士兵就像别人丢弃袜子一样。这公平吗？
I mean, I get the sense that it is probably. I think it's actually a bit harsh. I think blaming the generals for this is too harsh. They're in an impossible situation and it's, you know, it's Churchill's fault. It's not their fault. I think they, what do they do? I mean, they can't just sit there and do nothing. So, yeah, I think they're in an impossible situation, and it's the politician's fault for putting them there, frankly.
我的意思是，我感觉这可能是公平的。我认为这其实有点苛刻。我认为把这归咎于将军们太苛刻了。他们处于一种不可能的境地，而且，你知道，这是丘吉尔的错。这不是他们的错。我想他们，他们能做什么？我的意思是，他们不能只是坐在那里什么都不做。所以，是的，我认为他们处于一种不可能的境地，坦率地说，这是政客们的错，是他们把他们放在那里的。
But they are throwing away men, the way other men toss their ourselves. I mean, they was throwing away men. Yeah, but I mean, they keep thinking to themselves, well, maybe next time. No. And never. Yeah, of course. I mean, the bonkers thing is Churchill still won't shut up, even though he's been booted out. So the day after this battle, he was in Dundee addressing his constituents. And he said, through the narrows of the Dardanelles along the ridges of the Gallipoli Peninsula lies some of the shortest paths to a triumphant peace. Beyond those few miles of ridge and scrub on which our soldiers, our French comrades, our gallant Australians and our New Zealand fellow subjects, are now back. lie the downfall of a hostile empire, the destruction of an enemy's fleet and army, the fall of a world-famous capital, and probably the accession of powerful allies. And that's just bonkers from him. When he's coming out with that kind of stuff in the Second World War, it's great. And your heart sores and you feel a great patriotic glow.
但他们确实在丢弃士兵，就像别人丢弃袜子一样。我的意思是，他们确实在丢弃士兵。是的，但我的意思是，他们一直在想，也许下一次。不。永远不会。是的，当然。我的意思是，最疯狂的是丘吉尔即使被踢出局了，还是不肯闭嘴。所以在那场战斗后的第二天，他在邓迪向选民发表演讲。他说，穿过达达尼尔海峡的狭窄处，沿着加里波利半岛的山脊，通往胜利和平的道路是最短的路径之一。在那些我们的士兵、我们的法国同志、我们英勇的澳大利亚人和我们新西兰同胞们现在所处的几英里山脊和灌木丛之外，躺着一个敌对帝国的垮台，敌方舰队和军队的毁灭，一个世界著名首都的陷落，以及可能加入的强大盟友。这对他来说简直是疯了。当他在第二次世界大战中说出那种话时，那很棒。你的心会飞扬，你会感到一种伟大的爱国热情。
When he's coming out with that stuff in the face of a disaster like this, you just think that's mad. Of course you do. It's kind of bogus. the language is overinflated. Yeah. You know who it reminds me of there? And this will, I mean, who he undoubtedly is like, he is Boris Johnson at this point.
当他在面对这样的灾难时说出那种话，你只会觉得那是疯了。你当然会这么想。这有点虚假。语言太夸张了。是的。你知道他在那里让我想起了谁吗？这会，我的意思是，他无疑像谁，他就是此时的鲍里斯·约翰逊。
Yeah. Talking about Ukraine and everything that Britain should be doing for Ukraine, we haven't actually got any arms because his government has failed to invest in him. He's making wild promises and claims in the most grandiose rhetoric, while back in the office, the people working with him,
是的。谈论乌克兰以及英国应该为乌克兰做的一切，我们实际上没有任何武器，因为他的政府未能投资。他正在做出疯狂的承诺和主张，用最宏大的修辞，而回到办公室，与他一起工作的人，
in tears of frustration and rage because he's embarked on a course that's just utterly self-destructive and suicidal. But he's not the only one because two days later the new coalition, they've set up a sort of new war cabinet which they call the Dardanelles Committee, a sign of how important
充满了沮丧和愤怒的泪水，因为他走上了一条完全自我毁灭和自杀的道路。但他并不是唯一一个，因为两天后，新的联合政府，他们建立了一个新的战争内阁，他们称之为达达尼尔委员会，这标志着
the Dardanelles now is to them. And they said, well, what will we do? Shall we finally cut our losses? No, we won't. We'll actually send more men. So they say, we will send Serrian Hamilton his reinforcements. We will send four new divisions of Lord Kitchener's new army. And the generals on the Western front say, are you mad?
达达尼尔海峡现在对他们有多重要。他们说，好吧，我们该怎么办？我们终于要止损了吗？不，我们不会。我们实际上会派遣更多的人。所以他们说，我们将派遣伊恩·汉密尔顿爵士的增援部队。我们将派遣基奇纳勋爵新军的四个新师。而西线的将军们说，你们疯了吗？
When we need men so desperately against the Germans, why would you waste men on this mad lunatic scheme? So Douglas Haig, not an uncontroversial general himself, said at the time, he said, you could send the entire British army to Gallipoli, and it wouldn't make a blind bit of difference. You're never going to get a fleet through those straits. You're never going to capture Constantinople. You're never going to knock the Ottoman Empire out of the war.
当我们如此迫切地需要人力来对抗德国人时，为什么要在这个疯狂的疯子计划上浪费人力？所以道格拉斯·黑格，他本人也不是一位没有争议的将军，当时说，他说，你可以把整个英国军队派往加里波利，也不会有任何区别。你永远无法让舰队穿过那些海峡。你永远无法占领君士坦丁堡。你永远无法将奥斯曼帝国踢出战争。
You are deluding yourselves. And I quote, I think it is fatal to pour more troops in ammunition down the Dardanelles sink. But maybe he's wrong. Yeah, maybe. Maybe it'll work. Maybe one more heave will do the trick. Yeah. The date for the reinforcements to land is set for the 6th of August.
你们在自欺欺人。我引用一下，我认为把更多的部队和弹药投入达达尼尔海峡这个无底洞是致命的。但也许他是错的。是的，也许吧。也许它会奏效。也许再努力一次就能成功。是的。增援部队登陆的日期定在8月6日。
Hamilton is planning to land almost 30,000 fresh troops, at Sovlar Bay, which is just up the Gallipoli coast, and at the same time, the Anzaks will launch a massive breakout to capture the high ground in the centre of the peninsula. Well, I think when you put it like that, that might work. Yeah, I mean, that's sounding promising. These are the stakes. If this works, I think this could change the course of the Gallipoli campaign.
汉密尔顿计划在苏弗拉湾登陆近3万名生力军，就在加里波利海岸上方，与此同时，澳新军团将发动大规模突围，占领半岛中心的高地。嗯，我想当你这样说的时候，这可能会奏效。是的，我的意思是，这听起来很有希望。这就是赌注。如果这奏效，我认为这可能会改变加里波利战役的进程。
Which you know what it would result in? It would result in the downfall of a hostile empire, the destruction of an enemy's fleeting army, the fall of a world famous capital, and possibly the exertion of powerful allies. I think this could be the moment that wins the war. First World War, as everyone knows, ended in 1915. We'll be giving the details of that after the break.
你知道这会导致什么吗？这会导致一个敌对帝国的垮台，敌方舰队和军队的毁灭，一个世界著名首都的陷落，以及可能加入的强大盟友。我认为这可能是赢得战争的时刻。第一次世界大战，众所周知，结束于1915年。我们将在休息后提供细节。
Brilliant. This episode is brought to you by Disclosure Day. The new movie Disclosure Day is directed by legendary filmmaker Stephen Spielberg. And now with Disclosure Day, Spielberg is back with another movie which asks the fascinating question, what would you do if you found out that we here on planet Earth were not alone? See, I feel quite good about it because I've actually been. prepping for some years. So I've laid up stores. I've got weaponry. I'm ready. When the aliens
太棒了。本集由《披露日》赞助播出。新电影《披露日》由传奇电影制作人斯蒂芬·斯皮尔伯格执导。现在有了《披露日》，斯皮尔伯格带着另一部电影回归，提出了一个引人入胜的问题：如果你发现我们地球上的人并不孤单，你会怎么做？你看，我感觉很好，因为我实际上已经
attack, I will be able to fight back with the arsenal at my disposal. So I'm excited about it. But Dominic, you are not actually appearing in this cast because the cast is a really extraordinary one. And clearly Spielberg didn't need you because he's got Emily Blunt. He has got Colin Firth. He's got Josh O'Connor. He's got Coleman Domingo. And it's a completely gripping and original story and absolutely it demands to be seen not on TV but on the big screen Disclosure Day is in cinemas
准备好几年了。所以我储备了物资。我有武器。我准备好了。当外星人攻击时，我将能够用我掌握的武器库进行反击。所以我很兴奋。但是多米尼克，你并没有出现在这部电影的演员阵容中，因为演员阵容非常非凡。显然斯皮尔伯格不需要你，因为他有艾米丽·布朗特。他有科林·费尔斯。他有乔什·奥康纳。他有科尔曼·多明戈。这是一个完全引人入胜且原创的故事，绝对值得一看，不是在电视上，而是在大银幕上。《披露日》将于
Wednesday, June 10th so book your tickets now It's nearly that time everyone the rest is football will be on Netflix every day for the world's biggest tournament join myself Alan and Micah for daily debates unfiltered takes and the most special of guests all from the heart of New York City
6月10日星期三在电影院上映，所以现在就预订你的票吧。大家快到时间了，《足球的其余部分》将每天在Netflix上播出，迎接世界上最盛大的锦标赛。加入我和艾伦以及迈卡，进行每日辩论、未经过滤的观点和最特别的嘉宾，所有这些都来自纽约市中心。
Yeah, that's right. We're excited too. See you soon. Hey, this is Michael and Hannah from Gollhangers. The Rest is Science. This episode is brought to you by Cancer Research UK. In the UK, nearly one in two people will face cancer in their lifetime. The question is, could science stop cancer before it begins? In over the past 50 years, Cancer Research UK has helped double cancer survival in the UK. And that's proof of what research can achieve. Like take cervical cancer. Almost every case, is caused by HPV, the human papilloma virus. And when scientists uncovered that link, prevention became possible.
是的，没错。我们也感到很兴奋。很快再见。嘿，这是来自高尔汉格的迈克尔和汉娜。《科学的其余部分》。本集由英国癌症研究中心赞助。在英国，近二分之一的人一生中会面临癌症。问题是，科学能在癌症开始前阻止它吗？在过去的50年里，英国癌症研究中心帮助英国的癌症生存率翻了一番。这就是研究能取得成就的证明。比如宫颈癌。几乎每一个病例都是由HPV，即人乳头瘤病毒引起的。当科学家发现这种联系时，预防就成为可能。
Indeed, it did by a vaccine. And it's protection that works way before the cancer itself can actually grow. After the vaccine was introduced, cervical cancer rates in England were nearly 90% lower than expected in women in their 20s. I mean, we're now genuinely at a point where this is a disease that is disappearing in younger women in the UK. This is something that I really hope my daughters will never have to deal with. For more information about Cancer Research UK, their research, breakthroughs and how you can support them, visit cancer researchuk.org forward slash rest is science. Hello everyone. Welcome back to the rest is history. It is now the late summer of 1915. Glippily's been a
确实如此，通过疫苗。这种保护在癌症本身真正生长之前就起作用了。疫苗引入后，英国20多岁女性的宫颈癌发病率比预期的低了近90%。我的意思是，我们现在确实处于这样一个阶段，这种疾病在英国的年轻女性中正在消失。这是我真心希望我的女儿们永远不必面对的事情。有关英国癌症研究中心、他们的研究、突破以及你如何支持他们的更多信息，请访问 cancerresearchuk.org/restiscience。大家好。欢迎回到《历史的其余部分》。现在是1915年的夏末。加里波利一直是一场
total mess, but it's okay because the British government are sending reinforcements and this will undoubtedly enable the Allies to take Constantinople and to end the war in triumphant circumstances. Isn't that right, Dominic? That's what history tells us happened. It is indeed. So to remind people about the plan, they're going to land 27,000 fresh troops at Sovlar Bay, which is on the western side of the Gallipoli Peninsula, so the Aegean side. Meanwhile, those allied forces who are already on the peninsula, so Cape Helles, and at Anzac Cove, they will launch a series of attacks from their beachheads. This is known as the August defensive, and they will push the Turks back. They'll capture the Turkish trenches,
彻底的混乱，但没关系，因为英国政府正在派遣增援部队，这将无疑使盟军能够占领君士坦丁堡并在胜利的情况下结束战争。不是吗，多米尼克？这就是历史告诉我们发生的事情。确实如此。所以为了提醒人们这个计划，他们将在苏弗拉湾登陆27000名生力军，苏弗拉湾位于加里波利半岛的西侧，也就是爱琴海一侧。与此同时，那些已经在半岛上的盟军，也就是开普海勒斯和澳新军团湾，他们将从滩头阵地发动一系列攻击。这就是所谓的八月防御战，他们将把土耳其人赶回去。他们将占领土耳其人的战壕，
and they will seize the hills and the ridges that are further inland, so the commanding heights of the Gallipoli Peninsula. And all this is scheduled to begin on the evening of the 6th of August. And a big spoiler alert now, it doesn't go entirely according to plan. So if we begin with the landings at Sovlar Bay, the same old story. Basically, they do get the troops ashore, but they're under punishing Turkish fire. It's all a bit chaotic. Some of them arrive at the wrong point or the timings are wrong.
他们将夺取更内陆的山丘和山脊，也就是加里波利半岛的制高点。所有这些都定于8月6日晚上开始。现在有一个剧透警告，事情并没有完全按计划进行。所以如果我们从苏弗拉湾的登陆开始，还是老一套。基本上，他们确实让部队上了岸，但他们处于土耳其人猛烈的火力之下。一切都有点混乱。他们中的一些人到达了错误的地点，或者时间不对。
they take very heavy casualties and they don't make much progress at all. Basically, like before, all these blokes get stuck at their beachhead. They're pinned down as baking heat. They don't have supplies. They don't have any fresh water. And when they try to get inland, the Turks drive them back with their machine guns and with bayonet charges and things. I mean, I suppose to be fair to them, there's no way they could have worked out that that's what was going to happen. Because it's not like anyone's tried that before.
他们伤亡惨重，根本没有取得什么进展。基本上，就像以前一样，所有这些家伙都被困在滩头阵地。他们被困在酷热中。他们没有补给。他们没有任何淡水。当他们试图进入内陆时，土耳其人用机枪、刺刀冲锋等手段把他们赶了回去。我的意思是，我想公平地说，他们不可能算出会发生这种事。因为这不像以前有人尝试过。
How are they to know? And it's the same bloke who drives them back As drove them back before, Mustafa Kemmel. So he wasn't the initial commander at Suvler. There was another bloke, another Turk. He was sacked after a few days because of inertia. Mustafa Kemmel was sent in. Mustafa Kemal had been in the trenches all this time.
他们怎么会知道呢？而且把他们赶回去的还是那个家伙，就像之前赶走他们的人一样，穆斯塔法·凯末尔。所以他不是苏弗拉的最初指挥官。还有另一个家伙，另一个土耳其人。他因为惰性在几天后被解雇了。穆斯塔法·凯末尔被派了进去。穆斯塔法·凯末尔一直都在战壕里。
He was delighted to be leading the counterattack. He said, for four months, I'd live 300 metres away from the firing line, breathing the fetid smell of corpses. Having left in dungeon-like darkness at 11 o'clock that night, I was able to breathe clean air for the first time. So he's having a tremendous time. Although history might have been very different because at one point he's hit by a piece of shrapnel in the chest.
他很高兴能领导反击。他说，四个月来，我一直住在离火线300米远的地方，呼吸着尸体的恶臭。那天晚上11点离开地牢般的黑暗后，我第一次能够呼吸到新鲜空气。所以他过得很愉快。尽管历史可能非常不同，因为有一次他的胸部被一块弹片击中。
And the story goes, if you read in admiring biographies of Mustafa Kemal by Turkish historians, that he was saved by his watch. How did that work? Because the shrapnel hit him and he had his watch in his pocket. Oh, I see. Oh, right. Had that not happened, then who knows? Turkey might not exist.
故事是这样的，如果你读土耳其历史学家对穆斯塔法·凯末尔的赞美传记，他被他的手表救了。那是怎么回事？因为弹片击中了他，而他的手表在他的口袋里。哦，我明白了。哦，对。如果那没发生，那么谁知道呢？土耳其可能就不存在了。
Huge swathes of Turkey would be speaking Greek. The other big story of the day is the Australians and the New Zealanders attempt to break out of the Anzac Cove beachhead. I mean, you say there is another story that follows this, but we'll come to that when you've told this bit. So they're trying to break out of Anzac Cove. There's a whole series of battles that some of our Australian listeners will be very familiar with all these places called Lone Pine, Dead Man's Ridge, or the Neck. and they go down an Australian kind of legend basically they charge out and their machine gunned by Turks
土耳其的大片地区可能在说希腊语。那天另一个大故事是澳大利亚人和新西兰人试图突破澳新军团湾的滩头阵地。我的意思是，你说还有另一个故事紧随其后，但我们会在你讲完这一段后再谈。所以他们试图突破澳新军团湾。有一系列战斗，我们的一些澳大利亚听众会对所有这些地方非常熟悉，比如孤松、死人岭或颈部。他们进入了一种澳大利亚式的传奇，基本上他们冲了出去，被土耳其人用机枪扫射。
Sergeant Cliff Pinnock of the Victoria Light Horse said they were waiting ready for us and they simply gave us a solid wall of lead I was in the first line to advance and we didn't get 10 yards every one of those felt like lumps of meat all your pals that have been with you
维多利亚轻骑兵的克里夫·平诺克中士说，他们正等着我们，他们只是给了我们一堵坚实的铅墙。我是第一批推进的，我们连10码都没跑出去。那些人每一个都感觉像是一块块肉，所有那些和你在一起
for months and months blown and shot out of all recognition so to cut a very long story short this breakout attempt lasts four days. The Australians, you know, they fight heroically, but they lose more than 12,000 men killed or wounded. And it's, you know, they're basically pushed back into their beachhead. And in the film Gallipoli, the Peter Weir film that made Mel Gibson's name,
几个月又几个月的伙伴，被炸得、射得面目全非。所以长话短说，这次突围尝试持续了四天。澳大利亚人，你知道，他们英勇作战，但他们损失了超过12000人，阵亡或受伤。而且，你知道，他们基本上被赶回了滩头阵地。在电影《加里波利》中，那部让梅尔·吉布森成名的彼得·威尔电影，
it is claimed in this film that while the Australians are fighting and dying like lions, the British are playing in the sea and drinking tea on the beaches. This is a lie, a shameful lie. It's astonishing that Mel Gibson would associate himself with. Well, I'll tell you. Anglphobic propaganda. Mel Gibson really does hate Britain, doesn't he? He absolutely hates Britain.
这部电影声称，当澳大利亚人像狮子一样战斗和牺牲时，英国人在海里玩耍，在海滩上喝茶。这是一个谎言，一个可耻的谎言。梅尔·吉布森会把自己与这种东西联系起来真是令人震惊。嗯，我会告诉你的。恐英宣传。梅尔·吉布森真的很讨厌英国，不是吗？他绝对讨厌英国。
Well, let's be more precise. England. Yes, he does. I mean, can I tell you why he's wrong? Yeah, I do. He is overlooking what is the most significant episode in the whole Gallipoli campaign. I'm amazed you left this out. And this is the fate of the Sandringham Company.
嗯，让我们更精确一点。英格兰。是的，他确实讨厌。我的意思是，我能告诉你为什么他是错的吗？是的，我愿意。他忽略了整个加里波利战役中最重要的一集。我很惊讶你漏掉了这个。这就是桑德灵厄姆连的命运。
And these were basically a state, workers recruited from the royal estate in Norfolk in Sandringham. And they get that, you know, they're going off to serve King and Country in Gallipoli. And they get sent to, as part of this kind of attack to try and force the Turkish lines. And they march into a wooded, heavily defended area. And as they're pushing towards the Turks, they are lost to sight and sound. and a New Zealand forces engineer watches them go and he says that a low-hanging cloud
这些人基本上是诺福克桑德灵厄姆皇家庄园招募的工人。他们得到消息，你知道，他们要去加里波利为国王和国家服务。他们被派去，作为试图强攻土耳其防线的一部分。他们走进了一个树木繁茂、防御严密的地区。当他们向土耳其人推进时，他们消失在视线和声音之外。一位新西兰部队的工程师看着他们走进去，他说一朵低垂的云
which is loaf-shaped descends and it envelops the battalion and then it kind of goes up and when the cloud has gone, the battalion has gone as well. So there are two theories as to this. One is that it's, you know, hallucination, encourage, you know,
形状像面包，降下来，它包围了营队，然后它升起来了，当云散去时，营队也消失了。所以关于这一点有两种理论。一种是，你知道，幻觉，鼓励，你知道，
a result of the mist and the gunfire and the shell smoke and everything. think. Yeah. Also, sure you're driven mad by dysentery. Yeah, oh, they're dropping dead of dysentery or whatever. They just, they are kind of wiped out and they're never found. But the other theory, which I think is much more plausible, is that this is a UFO, a flying saucer that has descended and is interested in picking up human specimens for a future study. And they've come down and they've kind of picked up all the Sandringham estate workers who are now in the army and gone off whatever. and this was my introduction at the age of nine to the Gallipoli campaign.
雾气、枪声、炮烟和一切的结果。我想。是的。而且肯定是被痢疾折磨疯了。是的，哦，他们死于痢疾之类的。他们只是，他们被消灭了，再也没有被找到。但另一种理论，我认为更合理，是这是一个不明飞行物，一个降落并对收集人类样本进行未来研究感兴趣的飞碟。他们下来，把所有现在在军队里并离开的桑德灵厄姆庄园工人带走了，诸如此类。这就是我在九岁时对加里波利战役的介绍。
I read a whole book about it. Wow. It was a New Zealander who came up with this. Yeah, basically. The people from New Zealand are usually very level-headed. Well, I don't think he said that it was a flying saucer, because obviously people didn't know about flying saucers until after the Second World War, but it's a retrospective interpretation, this peculiar loaf-shaped cloud.
我读了一整本关于它的书。哇。是一个新西兰人想出了这个。是的，基本上。来自新西兰的人通常非常冷静。嗯，我不认为他说那是飞碟，因为显然人们直到第二次世界大战后才知道飞碟，但这是一种回顾性的解释，这朵奇特的面包状云。
Right. And actually, there was a BBC drama about it with David Jason as the commander of the Sandringham. Wow. He was like Carson in Downton Abbey going to war. So anyway, I just throw that out. All right, flying sources aside, where are we now? So Hamilton has got his reinforcements ashore. On the other hand, he hasn't made any dent in the Turkish defences, really.
对。而且实际上，有一个关于它的BBC电视剧，大卫·杰森饰演桑德灵厄姆的指挥官。哇。他就像《唐顿庄园》里去打仗的卡森。所以无论如何，我只是提一下。好吧，撇开飞碟不谈，我们现在在哪里？所以汉密尔顿已经让他的增援部队上岸了。另一方面，他并没有真正对土耳其的防御造成任何打击。
The tactical balance hasn't changed. Basically, everybody now knows this is an unbreakable stalemate. And it's, you know, this is basically trench warfare at its most tedious, at its most gruelling and attritional. We're into the summer. It's swelteringly hot, blistering sunshine, so they're all incredibly bad, the sunburned. The flies everywhere, the body's rotting, the dysentery is actually worse than ever. As Peter Hart says in his brilliant book, you know, they can look out, they can see the hospital ships at night with the lights twinkling in the darkness,
战术平衡没有改变。基本上，每个人现在都知道这是一个无法打破的僵局。而且，你知道，这基本上是堑壕战，最乏味、最艰苦、最消耗的。我们进入了夏天。天气酷热，阳光灼人，所以他们都晒伤得非常厉害。到处都是苍蝇，尸体腐烂，痢疾实际上比以往任何时候都严重。正如彼得·哈特在他那本出色的书中说的那样，你知道，他们可以向外看，他们可以在晚上看到医院船，灯光在黑暗中闪烁，
but all Gallipoli had to offer them was unending misery, disease and the threat of death. So after the Sovlar landings, two other important things happen. So number one is there has been another of these bidding wars with the Ottoman Empire's neighbor, Bulgaria. And the Bulgarians have been shopping around as the Italians and the Ottomans had before them. They were, the Bulgarians felt very cheated because they'd fought the first Balkan war with their neighbors against the Ottomans. But then their neighbors, Serbia, Greece and Romania, had all ganged up on them and basically taken the Bulgarians gains. So the Bulgarians are very cross and they want to get a better deal. They decide by the late summer, early autumn of 1915, that the Allies are a complete shambles and the central powers are going to win.
但加里波利能给他们的只有无尽的苦难、疾病和死亡的威胁。所以在苏弗拉登陆后，又发生了两件重要的事情。第一件事是与奥斯曼帝国的邻国保加利亚又发生了一场竞标战。保加利亚人一直在四处打听，就像之前的意大利人和奥斯曼人一样。他们，保加利亚人感到非常受骗，因为他们曾与邻国一起在第一次巴尔干战争中对抗奥斯曼人。但后来他们的邻国塞尔维亚、希腊和罗马尼亚都联合起来对付他们，基本上夺走了保加利亚人的战果。所以保加利亚人非常生气，他们想达成更好的交易。到1915年的夏末秋初，他们决定盟军是一团糟，而同盟国将会获胜。
And they sign a secret treaty with the Germans and then they enter the war and attack Serbia. I mean, I'm sad about that. I'm sad about that because I'm very, very fond of Bulgaria. thanks to Simon, my Bulgarian personal trainer, to who might owe so much three wickets at the weekend, just mentioning that. But I can understand it. So two things. First of all, I myself am a massive Bulgarophile because I've been travelling backpacking twice around Bulgaria. Okay, okay.
他们与德国人签署了一项秘密条约，然后他们加入了战争并攻击塞尔维亚。我的意思是，我对此感到难过。我对此感到难过，因为我非常、非常喜欢保加利亚。多亏了西蒙，我的保加利亚私人教练，周末欠他三个三柱门，只是提一下。但我能理解。所以两件事。首先，我自己是一个巨大的保加利亚迷，因为我曾两次在保加利亚背包旅行。好吧，好吧。
So it's a meeting of mines. That's unexpected. Yeah. I love Bulgaria. I've been to Provdiv. I've been to Voliko Tarnvo, all kinds of tremendous places in Bulgaria. Oh, we had a great time in Plovtiv. Saw Nick Cave in the...
所以这是思想的碰撞。这出乎意料。是的。我爱保加利亚。我去过普罗夫迪夫。我去过大特尔诺沃，保加利亚各种各样了不起的地方。哦，我们在普罗夫迪夫玩得很开心。在……看了尼克·凯夫。
Roman theatre there. It was brilliant. Right. I didn't see Nick Cave. I saw a, it was in late 1990s. It was a strange folk dancing festival in which the stage literally collapsed under the feet of a Serbian pantomime horse. God, what a great country. Also, actually, talking of toilets, some of the worst toilets I've ever seen are on the Turkish-Bulgarian border. Anyway, that's by the bye. So it's sad, but...
那里的罗马剧院。太棒了。对。我没看到尼克·凯夫。我看到一个，那是在1990年代末。那是一个奇怪的民间舞蹈节，舞台在塞尔维亚哑剧马的脚下真的塌了。天哪，多好的国家。另外，实际上，说到厕所，我见过的最糟糕的一些厕所在土耳其-保加利亚边境。无论如何，那是题外话。所以这很悲伤，但是……
But the Bulgarians are not on the wrong side. Britain is on the wrong side. You want to be with the... Come on. You want to be with the Ottoman Empire. the Bulgarians, the Austro-Hungarian Empire and our friends, the Germans, we've made a massive, we've had a shocker. Anyway, so essentially, Bulgaria's entered the war against us, and so that's now a problem, right?
但保加利亚人不在错误的一边。英国在错误的一边。你想和……得了吧。你想和奥斯曼帝国、保加利亚人、奥匈帝国和我们的朋友德国人在一起，我们犯了一个巨大的错误，我们表现得很糟糕。无论如何，所以基本上，保加利亚已经对我们宣战了，所以现在是个问题，对吧？
Yeah, a massive problem, because they're in the Balkans. Your whole Constantinople scheme now looks ridiculous. It's looking even, I mean, it's looking ridiculous now. Yeah, yeah, it's looking bad before. It's looking really bad now the Bulgarians, who are the Ottoman Empire's northern neighbours, have also entered. and the other thing is after the Sovlar landings
是的，一个巨大的问题，因为他们在巴尔干半岛。你整个君士坦丁堡计划现在看起来很荒谬。它看起来甚至，我的意思是，它现在看起来很荒谬。是的，是的，它之前看起来很糟糕。现在看起来真的很糟糕，因为作为奥斯曼帝国北部邻国的保加利亚人也加入了。另一件事是苏弗拉登陆后
there's a shift in public opinion in Britain so for the first time people are now openly saying this campaign they're openly saying it in the newspapers this campaign's not going according to plan
英国的公众舆论发生了转变，所以这是第一次人们现在公开说这场战役，他们在报纸上公开说这场战役没有按计划进行。
and the most famous example of somebody who says this is a young reporter from Melbourne called Keith Murdoch and he is the father of Rupert Murdoch so that's where it all originates It is. Well, this is a big moment in, so this is a very well-known moment in Australian history, and particularly Australian media history. So Keith Murdoch worked for the Sun, a newspaper in Sydney. And in the late summer of 1915, he went to Anzac Cove, and then he went on to Allied headquarters on the island of Imbros. And there, he was befriended by the bloat we mentioned last time, Ellis Ashmead Bartlett of the Daily Telegraph.
而说这话的人中最著名的一个是来自墨尔本的年轻记者，名叫基思·默多克，他是鲁珀特·默多克的父亲，所以这就是一切的起源。确实是。嗯，这是一个大时刻，所以这是澳大利亚历史上，特别是澳大利亚媒体历史上一个非常著名的时刻。所以基思·默多克为悉尼的一家报纸《太阳报》工作。1915年夏末，他去了澳新军团湾，然后去了位于因布罗斯岛的盟军总部。在那里，他与我们上次提到的那个家伙，每日电讯报的埃利斯·阿什米德·巴特利特结为了朋友。
So here's the bloke who had written the first reports of the Anzac landing and had basically created the idea of exceptional Australian New Zealand heroism. And Ashmead Bartlett, who's British, says to Keith Murdoch, this campaign is a total disaster. Hamilton is useless, they're all useless. And because of wartime censorship, people in London aren't getting the truth. And he gives Keith Murdoch a letter, basically a report, and he says, I want you to take this to London and give it to Askwith personally.
所以这就是那个写了澳新军团登陆第一篇报道，并基本上创造了澳大利亚和新西兰英雄主义例外论的人。而阿什米德·巴特利特，他是英国人，对基思·默多克说，这场战役是一场彻底的灾难。汉密尔顿没用，他们都没用。由于战时审查制度，伦敦的人们没有得到真相。他给了基思·默多克一封信，基本上是一份报告，他说，我希望你把它带到伦敦，亲自交给阿斯奎斯。
Murdoch goes off by ship. When he gets to Marseille, he's intercepted by British military police. The top brass are found out about this letter, and the letter is confiscated from Keith Murdoch. So he goes on, and he gets to London, and now he writes a report of his own for the Australian Prime Minister Andrew Fisher, who is a friend of Keith Murdox.
默多克乘船离开。当他到达马赛时，他被英国宪兵拦截了。高层发现了这封信，信被从基思·默多克那里没收了。所以他继续前进，到达了伦敦，现在他为澳大利亚总理安德鲁·费舍尔写了一份他自己的报告，费舍尔是基思·默多克的朋友。
And Murdoch, it will amaze people familiar with journalism, and the way that some elements of the press behave, that Keith Murdoch writes this incredibly exaggerated, embellished version of the previous report. He says, the entire operation, I mean, this bit's not wrong at all, has been one of the most terrible chapters in our history, a series of disastrous underestimations. Now, this is sad from Keith Murdoch, and he lets himself down. He's very rude about the British soldiers.
而默多克，这会让熟悉新闻业以及媒体某些部分行为方式的人感到惊讶，基思·默多克写了这个极其夸张、润色过的先前报告的版本。他说，整个行动，我的意思是，这一部分一点也不错，是我们历史上最可怕的篇章之一，一系列灾难性的低估。现在，这对于基思·默多克来说很悲哀，他让自己失望了。他对英国士兵非常粗鲁。
He says they're not to be compared with the Australians, and their physique is very much below that of the Turks. Pie-chuckers. They are merely a lot of childlike youths without strength to endure or brains to improve their lot. I mean, this is such sledging from the Australians. Yeah, it really is. It's very ashes punditory, isn't it?
他说他们不能与澳大利亚人相比，他们的体格远低于土耳其人。废物。他们只是一群没有力量忍受或没有大脑改善自己命运的幼稚青年。我的意思是，这是澳大利亚人如此尖刻的批评。是的，确实是。这非常像板球比赛的嘲讽，不是吗？
David Boone. He goes on to say, the real fault, though, the British soldiers are useless, feckless, weak, stupid, but the British officers are worse. The continuous and ghastly bungling over the Dardanelles Enterprise was to be expected. from such a general staff as the British army possesses,
大卫·布恩。他继续说，真正的错误在于，英国士兵没用、软弱、愚蠢，但英国军官更糟。达达尼尔海峡企业的持续和可怕的拙劣表现是可以预料到的。从英国军队拥有的这种总参谋部来看，
the conceit and self-complacency of the red-feather men are equaled only by their incapacity. Anyway, Keith Murdoch has become pals with David Lloyd George, and he tells David Lloyd George this, and Lloyd George says, I want you to send a copy of this to ask with. And meanwhile, the telegraph bloke, Ashmead Bartlett, he's now arrived in London too.
红羽毛男人的自负和自满只能与他们的无能相提并论。无论如何，基思·默多克已经和戴维·劳合·乔治成为了朋友，他告诉了戴维·劳合·乔治这件事，劳合·乔治说，我希望你把这份报告的副本寄给阿斯奎斯。与此同时，电讯报的那个家伙，阿什米德·巴特利特，他也到达了伦敦。
He's been sent home from Gallipoli, and he goes and he meets Lord Northcliff, the most powerful press baron of the day, and he says the operation is a shambles. So thanks to Murdoch and Ashmead Bartlett, all kind of London high society, political kind of classes, all those kind of people in the kind of salons of Westminster and Whitehall, they're talking about what a nightmare the campaign has become. And so by early October, instead of saying, are we going to call it off, people are actually saying, well, when are we going to call it off? Do they accept any kind of responsibility?
他被从加里波利送回了家，他去见了当时最有权势的报业大亨诺斯克利夫勋爵，他说这次行动是一团糟。所以多亏了默多克和阿什米德·巴特利特，伦敦上流社会、政治阶层，所有那些在威斯敏斯特和白厅沙龙里的人，都在谈论这场战役已经变成了一场噩梦。所以到10月初，人们不再说，我们要取消它吗，而是实际上在说，我们什么时候取消它？他们承担任何责任吗？
The politicians. Or do they just blame the officers and the commanders? I think they blame Winston Churchill. They have an excellent scapegoats. They have an excellent scapegoat. But they start sacking everybody, don't they? All the kind of military top brass. They do?
政客们。还是他们只是把责任推给军官和指挥官？我认为他们把责任推给了温斯顿·丘吉尔。他们有极好的替罪羊。他们有极好的替罪羊。但他们开始解雇所有人，不是吗？所有那些军事高层。他们解雇了吗？
They keep changing all the generals, of course. But when they do that, do they say, actually, we're complicit in this? We've really screwed up here. No. No one ever does that. No, I guess not. So Kitchener, who definitely is complicit in it, by the way, Kitchener said to Ian Hamilton, sort of early October,
他们当然一直在更换所有的将军。但当他们这样做时，他们会说，实际上，我们对此有同谋吗？我们在这里真的搞砸了吗？不。从来没有人那样做。不，我想没有。所以基奇纳，顺便说一句，他绝对是同谋，基奇纳在10月初对伊恩·汉密尔顿说，
I want you to think about an evacuation. How many men do you think you would lose? And Hamilton says, you know, an evacuation is a terrible idea. We would lose half our men. I mean, this is one reason why they don't get off, by the way, because a lot of the top brass think, if we start evacuating, we'll be sitting ducks on the beaches and the Turks will just kill us all.
我想让你考虑一下撤离。你认为你会损失多少人？汉密尔顿说，你知道，撤离是一个可怕的主意。我们会损失一半的人。我的意思是，这也是他们没有撤离的一个原因，顺便说一句，因为许多高层认为，如果我们开始撤离，我们就会成为海滩上的活靶子，土耳其人会把我们全部杀光。
So we're stuck. Anyway, after Hamilton said that, the war council said, okay, Hamilton's got to go. His career is basically over. They sack him. and they send a guy called Charles Monroe who'd been on the western front near Eap. Monroe went to Gallipoli.
所以我们被困住了。无论如何，在汉密尔顿说了那番话后，战争委员会说，好吧，汉密尔顿必须走。他的职业生涯基本上结束了。他们解雇了他。他们派了一个叫查尔斯·门罗的人，他曾在伊普尔附近的西线服役。门罗去了加里波利。
He spent three days touring the beachheads. After three days he said, OK, I've had a look. This is madness. We've got to get out of here. This is hopeless. When the word gets back to London, Churchill, who's still actually in the government
他花了三天时间巡视滩头阵地。三天后他说，好吧，我看过了。这太疯狂了。我们必须离开这里。这毫无希望。当消息传回伦敦时，丘吉尔，他实际上还在政府里
with this kind of non-job, Churchill went absolutely ballistic. He said, this would be the greatest disaster since the loss of the American coloners. And they said, well, what would you do? And he said, maybe you have another crack at the straits with some ships and some more men. I mean, that's, that's ridiculous at that point. So he's lost the plot. The war council says no. Churchill flounces out of the government completely.
对于这种有名无实的职位，丘吉尔彻底暴怒了。他说，这将是自失去美洲殖民地以来最大的灾难。他们问，那你打算怎么办？他说，也许可以用一些船只和更多的人手再试一次海峡。我的意思是，在那一点上，这太荒谬了。所以他已经失去了理智。战争委员会拒绝了。丘吉尔愤然退出了政府。
He sends a resignation letter to Asquith and says, I have a clear conscience, time will vindicate my administration of the Admiralty, which is not true at all. But then to his credit, remember, he's only 41. Churchill then tries to redeem himself. He goes to the Western Front. He becomes the lieutenant colonel and the Scots fuseliers and he serves, you know, he doesn't really see that much action. There's constant bombardment and he is almost killed, I think, by a shell
他给阿斯奎斯写了一封辞职信，说他问心无愧，时间会证明他管理海军部的正确性，但这完全不是事实。但值得称赞的是，别忘了，他当时才41岁。丘吉尔随后试图自我救赎。他去了西线。他成为了苏格兰燧发枪团的中校，并服役，你知道，他并没有真正经历太多的战斗。那里有不断的炮击，我想他差点被一颗炮弹炸死。
at one point. So he does put himself in harm's way and I think this is the point where the comparison with, yeah, Boris Johnson evaporates and indeed, I mean, you think about all those disgraced ministers in the last government, sort of Matt Hancock or whatever. I mean, they did not do anything like this. They did
有一次。所以他确实让自己身处险境，我认为这就是与鲍里斯·约翰逊的比较完全站不住脚的地方，事实上，想想上一届政府中所有那些名誉扫地的部长，比如马特·汉考克之流。我的意思是，他们根本没有做过任何类似的事情。他们做了
reality TV programs. Matt Hancock went off and got trained by the SAS, I think. Yeah, there's a brilliant clip online of an SAS man shouting at him. You're a, I can't say the word, what are you? And a miserable Matt Hancock, the man who'd been in charge of our COVID response, standing there on Channel 5 or whatever, being berated by the SAS. I mean, what you can't say about Churchill is that he was ever a coward.
真人秀节目。马特·汉考克跑去接受了特种空勤团（SAS）的训练，我想是这样。是的，网上有一个精彩的片段，一个SAS队员对他大喊大叫。你是个，我不能说那个词，你是什么？而一个可怜的马特·汉考克，那个曾经负责我们新冠疫情应对的人，站在第五频道之类的节目里，被SAS训斥。我的意思是，你不能说丘吉尔是个懦夫。
No. I mean, he was insanely brave. And when he said that he loved war, I mean, he genuinely meant it. He did. I mean, he. this has not been his finest hour by any means. No. It's always been the great blot on his escutcheon, hasn't it?
不。我的意思是，他极其勇敢。当他说他热爱战争时，他是真心的。他确实热爱。我的意思是，他……这绝不是他最辉煌的时刻。不。这一直是他名誉上的污点，不是吗？
Yeah, yeah. And we'll maybe talk about that. It's right at the end. The men at Gallipoli. Back to them. You can't evacuate people overnight. And that means that they are going to have to stay there for a few more weeks. They're basically going to have to stay there into the winter.
是的，是的。我们也许会谈谈这一点。就在最后。加里波利的士兵们。回到他们身上。你不可能一夜之间撤离所有人。这意味着他们将不得不留在那里再待几周。他们基本上必须在那里待到冬天。
At the end of November, the weather turns. It's really cold. It's rainy. It's windy. And then it starts to snow. Tragically, many of the British and Anzaks are still in their thursday. thin summer uniforms. So thousands of them get frostbite
11月底，天气转冷。非常冷。下着雨，刮着风。然后开始下雪。可悲的是，许多英国士兵和澳新军团士兵仍然穿着他们单薄的夏季制服。所以成千上万的人患上了冻疮
and a lot of them literally freeze to death. I mean, there are stories about when it starts raining in the trenches filled with rainwater and some of them are so weak with dysentery that they can't pull themselves out and they just lie there and they drown. Oh dear. So there's a story lieutenant in the field ambulance. He describes
很多人真的冻死了。我的意思是，有一些故事说，当战壕里开始下雨，积满了雨水，有些人因为痢疾而虚弱得无法爬出来，他们就躺在那里淹死了。噢，天哪。所以有一个野战救护队中尉的故事。他描述了
seeing an officer, his feet were frozen and he was making his way to our dressing station. He asked two others who were with him to go on and he sat down in the mud. They went on, and they sent back stretcher bearers. But when the bearers reached him, he was dead of cold and exhaustion.
看到一名军官，他的脚冻伤了，他正艰难地走向我们的包扎站。他让和他在一起的另外两个人先走，然后他坐在了泥地里。他们继续前行，并派回了担架队。但当担架队找到他时，他已经因寒冷和精疲力竭而死亡。
And this is a very, very common story. So the first evacuations, which are at Suvler and at Anzac Cove, are scheduled for late December. Hamilton had said he would lose half his men. And in this he was actually quite wrong. I mean, this is the one example of being too pessimistic. This is the one bit of the operation.
这是一个非常、非常普遍的故事。所以，苏弗拉和澳新军团湾的首次撤离定于12月下旬。汉密尔顿曾说他会损失一半的兵力。在这点上他实际上相当错误。我的意思是，这是过于悲观的一个例子。这是行动中唯一的一点。
It really is a spectacular success. They do it over several nights, so the Turks don't detect them. They do lots of clever things with their guns, so the guns will keep firing. They set them, they rig them, so they'll fire regular intervals. Never. So that the Turks won't realize they're running away.
这确实是一个壮观的成功。他们分几个晚上进行，所以土耳其人没有发现他们。他们用枪支做了很多巧妙的事情，所以枪支会继续射击。他们设置了它们，操纵了它们，让它们以固定的间隔射击。从不停止。这样土耳其人就不会意识到他们在逃跑。
I think withdrawing, Dominic. They're not running away. They're withdrawing. Withdrawing. Okay. Yeah, running away is too harsh. So they are taken off the beaches on the night of the 20th of December, about 80,000 of them.
我想是撤退，多米尼克。他们不是在逃跑。他们是在撤退。撤退。好吧。是的，逃跑太刺耳了。所以他们在12月20日晚上被撤离海滩，大约8万人。
They leave a load of their kit behind, but they lose almost no lives at all. It's a remarkable achievement. And it was later said of Clement Attlee, who has come back to Gallipoli, after his bout of dysentery, that he was the second to last man off the beach, Savler, or something like that. I don't know how anyone would ever be able to prove this or calculate it. But anyway, he's one of the last to leave. I guess it's a reflection of kind of a sense of his courage. Yeah, exactly.
他们留下了一大堆装备，但几乎没有损失任何生命。这是一个了不起的成就。后来有人说，在痢疾发作后回到加里波利的克莱门特·艾德礼是倒数第二个离开苏弗拉海滩的人，或者类似的话。我不知道有谁能证明或计算出这一点。但无论如何，他是最后离开的人之一。我想这反映了他的一种勇气。是的，完全正确。
You know, how well he's performed. Exactly. The men at Cape Hellies, so mainly British, they had to wait another couple of weeks. The operation started on the 7th of January. There's a huge bombardment by the ships. That gives them, allows them to pull back. They're a little bit inland by this point, about five miles in land. So they pull back to the beaches.
你知道，他表现得有多好。完全正确。海丽斯角的士兵，主要是英国人，他们不得不又等了几周。行动于1月7日开始。船只进行了大规模的炮击。这给了他们机会，让他们能够撤退。此时他们已经在内陆一点，大约五英里深处。所以他们撤回了海滩。
And then the very last troops to leave, which are the Newfoundland Regiment, they left at 4 a.m. on the 9th of January. And again, they didn't really suffer any casualties at all. And for a lot of the men, this was obviously a bittersweet, even traumatic moment to leave behind after so much had been sacrificed. So I quoted earlier a guy called Joe Murray, who was an ordinary seaman in the Royal Naval Division. He was looking back later on. He said, as we got further from the line, I remember the advance we'd had on May the 6th, when more of my pals died, such as Petty Officer Warren and Young Yates. I could still hear young Horton crying for his mother as he died.
然后最后一批离开的部队，即纽芬兰团，他们在1月9日凌晨4点离开。同样，他们几乎没有遭受任何伤亡。对于许多士兵来说，这显然是一个苦乐参半，甚至是痛苦的时刻，在牺牲了这么多之后不得不离开。所以我之前引用了一个叫乔·默里的人的话，他是皇家海军师的一名普通水兵。他后来回顾时说，当我们离前线越来越远时，我记得5月6日的进攻，当时我更多的伙伴死了，比如沃伦军士长和年轻的耶茨。我还能听到年轻的霍顿死前呼唤母亲的声音。
And I remembered Colonel Quilter leading the advance and going to his death armed with a huge walking stick, very British behaviour. The tears were streaming down my cheeks, I just couldn't restrain them. My eyes were smarting so much I think I walked the rest of the way with my eyes closed. I knew it so well, though, I couldn't go wrong. So it was all for nothing. One of the great British military disasters, and you actually made this point a little bit earlier. The plans were unrealistic. They were incoherent. They were poorly organized, all of this kind of thing. But the mad thing is, even if the Gallipoli campaign had worked. So what? So what? Does no guarantee they could have got the fleet through the straits
我记得库尔特上校带领进攻并走向死亡，手里拿着一根巨大的手杖，非常英国式的行为。泪水顺着我的脸颊流下来，我无法抑制。我的眼睛刺痛得厉害，我想我闭着眼睛走完了剩下的路。但我太熟悉它了，所以我不会走错。所以这一切都是徒劳的。这是英国历史上最伟大的军事灾难之一，你刚才确实提到了这一点。计划是不现实的。它们是不连贯的，组织得很差，诸如此类。但疯狂的是，即使加里波利战役成功了又怎样？又怎样？并不能保证他们能让舰队通过海峡
because they've only secured one side of the straits. There's still all the forts on the other side. Yeah. And imagine they've got their fleet through. They don't have enough men to occupy Constantinople. So the fleet arrives outside Constantinople and they fire at the Constantinople
因为他们只控制了海峡的一侧。另一侧还有所有的堡垒。是的。想象一下他们让舰队通过了。他们没有足够的兵力占领君士坦丁堡。所以舰队到达君士坦丁堡外，他们向君士坦丁堡开火
and the Turks just fire back at them. Greek fire. Yeah, then what? What do they do then? The Ottomans aren't going to change sides. As Peter Hart says in his brilliant book on Gallipoli, the whole thing was just a complete distraction from the Western Front because basically they couldn't accept,
而土耳其人只是向他们还击。希腊火。是的，然后呢？他们那时该怎么办？奥斯曼人不会倒戈的。正如彼得·哈特在他关于加里波利的精彩著作中所说，整件事完全是对西线战场的干扰，因为基本上他们无法接受，
they got themselves into a war that was going to be a really grueling war of attrition and it would take years to win it. There were no shortcuts. Yeah, there's no shortcuts. And Churchill is definitely the primary culprit. Even Andrew Roberts in his biography says, you know, he's the scapegoat in chief
他们陷入了一场将是一场非常艰苦的消耗战，需要数年时间才能赢得胜利。没有捷径。是的，没有捷径。丘吉尔绝对是主要的罪魁祸首。即使是安德鲁·罗伯茨在他的传记中也说，你知道，他是首席替罪羊
but he deserves to be the scapegoat in chief. It's not just that it's his idea originally. I mean, people often come up with ideas that don't work in politics or in war. It's the fact that even after it is demonstrably failing, he will not give it up and he's still vigorously campaigning for it at a point when other people, you know, have woken up to the reality of it. It's the very worst side of Churchill, the irresponsibility, the recklessness, the kind of stubbornness. In the commons, when he was defending himself in his resignation statement, he said he thought it was a legitimate.
但他理应成为首席替罪羊。不仅仅是因为这最初是他的主意。我的意思是，人们在政治或战争中经常提出行不通的想法。事实是，即使在它被证明失败后，他也不愿放弃，并且在其他人已经意识到现实的时候，他仍然在积极地为它奔走。这是丘吉尔最糟糕的一面，不负责任，鲁莽，那种固执。在下议院，当他在辞职声明中为自己辩护时，他说他认为这是一次合法的
legitimate war gamble with stakes that we could afford to lose for a prize of inestimable value. And people slammed him afterwards. They said that is classic Churchill. He's a gambler. But then the shocking thing about that to me is not the word gamble. It's the stakes we could afford to lose because the stakes, he's talking about people. Yeah. And a lot of people. Well, he's talking about all those people dying in puddles of their own excrement. Exactly. So to give people a sense, in total casualties, so that includes wounded, sing and so on sick British and Anzac's
合法的战争赌博，赌注是我们输得起的，为了一个无价的奖品。事后人们抨击他。他们说那是典型的丘吉尔。他是个赌徒。但对我来说，其中令人震惊的不是“赌博”这个词。而是“我们输得起的赌注”，因为赌注，他指的是人。是的。而且是很多人。好吧，他指的是所有那些死在自己排泄物水坑里的人。完全正确。所以为了让人们有个概念，总伤亡人数，包括受伤、失踪等等，生病的英国和澳新军团士兵
200,000 men, the French 47,000 the Turks, a quarter of a million. In deaths alone, the British and Irish troops lost 30,000, the French 12,000, Ansax's 11,000. Again, the Turks, who are always forgotten in accounts, I mean, not in Turkey, but in allied kind of English language accounts,
20万人，法国人4.7万人，土耳其人25万人。仅死亡人数，英爱军队损失了3万人，法国人1.2万人，澳新军团1.1万人。同样，土耳其人，他们在叙述中总是被遗忘，我的意思是，在土耳其不是，但在盟军那种英语叙述中，
they lost 86,000 men killed, which is a lot. So that surprises me It's a bit like with the Italians and the Austrians that actually the Turks, even though they were defending, they lost more. Yeah. Well, don't forget they're not always defending because sometimes they are on the,
他们损失了8.6万名士兵，这很多。这让我感到惊讶。这有点像意大利人和奥地利人的情况，实际上土耳其人，尽管他们是在防御，但他们损失更多。是的。好吧，别忘了他们并不总是防御，因为有时他们是在
they're trying to push them back into the sea. And of course, the Turks are, you know, they are on home ground, but they are technologically industrially behind. So their equipment's not as good. Yeah. You know, it's not like the British and the Anzaks and whatnot and the French aren't good of fighting.
他们试图把他们赶回海里。当然，土耳其人，你知道，他们是在本土作战，但他们在技术和工业上落后。所以他们的装备不如对方。是的。你知道，这并不是说英国人和澳新军团之类的以及法国人不善于战斗。
They are good of fighting and they kill a lot of Turks. But yeah, you're right. I think it's precisely because they are not, they're not just sitting there waiting for them to come onto them. They're actively trying to drive them back. For Churchill, you said it was the great stain on his reputation, and you're right. It took years for the humiliation to fade. People would shout at him at public meetings well into the 1930s.
他们善于战斗，他们杀死了许多土耳其人。但是的，你是对的。我认为正是因为他们不仅仅是坐在那里等着对方过来。他们是在积极地试图把他们赶回去。对于丘吉尔，你说这是他名誉上的巨大污点，你是对的。这种羞辱过了好几年才消退。直到20世纪30年代，人们在公开会议上还会对他大喊大叫。
What about the Dardanelles? You know, when he's talking about Hitler, for example, there are still people who won't forgive him for Gallipoli. There were people, posh people in London, kind of society hostesses and whatnot, who would walk into a room and they would see Churchill there or even just his wife, Clemmy, and they would walk out again. I will not be in a room with the man who sent my husband, my son, my brother to die for his own vanity in this mad scheme. Do you think he learns lessons from it? Well, to a degree. You know, Andrew Roberts in his biography says of Churchill, he's more cautious about Mission Creek.
达达尼尔海峡怎么样？你知道，当他谈论希特勒时，例如，仍然有人不会原谅他在加里波利的所作所为。有些人，伦敦的上流人士，那种社交名媛之类的，当他们走进一个房间看到丘吉尔在那里，甚至只是他的妻子克莱米，他们就会走出去。我不会和一个为了自己的虚荣心，在这个疯狂的计划中送我丈夫、我儿子、我兄弟去死的人待在一个房间里。你认为他从中吸取了教训吗？嗯，在某种程度上。你知道，安德鲁·罗伯茨在他的传记中说丘吉尔，他对任务蔓延更加谨慎了。
He is quicker to sack generals who are no good. He is quicker to cut his losses. That said, he still loves a mad scheme, doesn't he? He does. In the Second World War, his generals are still having to argue him out of mad, lunatic schemes and whatnot. So did he really learn from it? I don't think he did, actually. I think it's always part of his character.
他更快地解雇那些不称职的将军。他更快地止损。话虽如此，他仍然喜欢疯狂的计划，不是吗？他确实喜欢。在第二次世界大战中，他的将军们仍然不得不争论劝阻他放弃疯狂、荒唐的计划等等。所以他真的从中吸取教训了吗？我不认为他真的吸取了。我认为这始终是他性格的一部分。
And perhaps one of the remarkable things is that in the Second World War, when he's at his best, he is constrained by circumstance because Britain is at bay and so he can't get up to mad lunatic schemes but I think left to him he never loses that sort of boyish that boyish fondness for a stunt but unfortunately a stunt that could cost thousands and thousands of lives as it did in this case
也许令人瞩目的一点是，在第二次世界大战中，当他处于最佳状态时，他受到环境的限制，因为英国处于绝境，所以他无法搞出疯狂的荒唐计划，但我认为如果任由他，他永远不会失去那种孩子气的、那种对特技的喜爱，但不幸的是，这种特技可能会像本案中那样付出成千上万人的生命。
the big winner obviously is Mustafa Kemmel in his brilliant book on Ataturk, Andrew Mango his biographer says, you know, it's the foundation of his career. It makes his name in the army, and it means that when the Ottoman Empire collapses in 1990, and it looks as though Turkey itself kind of at the Anatolian heartland is going to be completely dismembered. It's to Mustafa Kemmel that the army turns as its savior, and people remember him saying at Anzac Cove, I don't order you to attack, I order you to die. And people say, God, what a brilliant line this is. What Churchillian, I suppose.
最大的赢家显然是穆斯塔法·凯末尔，在他关于阿塔图尔克的精彩著作中，他的传记作者安德鲁·曼戈说，你知道，这是他职业生涯的基础。这让他在军队中声名鹊起，这意味着当奥斯曼帝国在1919年崩溃时，看起来土耳其本身，那种安纳托利亚的核心地带，似乎要被彻底肢解。正是穆斯塔法·凯末尔让军队转向他作为救星，人们记得他在澳新军团湾说，我不命令你们进攻，我命令你们去死。人们说，天哪，这真是一句精彩的话。我想这很丘吉尔。
this is the kind of spirit we need now when we're all falling apart. And so it becomes part of his legend, I guess, and allows him to turn himself into Ataturk, kind of the father, father Turk or whatever, which is his nickname. I mean, I suppose to, because what he goes on to do is essentially to kind of cut Turkey's losses. Yeah. He has the military reputation that enables him to do that. People, except this is a guy who defended the homeland and threw the great imperial power back into the sea. So we can
这就是我们现在分崩离析时所需要的精神。所以这成为了他传奇的一部分，我想，并让他把自己变成了阿塔图尔克，某种“土耳其之父”之类的，这是他的绰号。我的意思是，我想也是，因为他接下来所做的事情本质上是某种程度上止损。是的。他拥有使他能够做到这一点的军事声誉。人们接受这是一个保卫了家园并将伟大的帝国力量赶回海里的人。所以我们可以
trust him to do what he thinks is necessary. And if he hadn't had that, it might not have been possible. I think it's also important with Mustafa Kemmel that he'd lost his own birthplace and never got it back. Yeah, of course. I mean, Solonica, Thessaloniki. Anyway, we'll
信任他去做他认为必要的事情。如果他没有那个，这可能是不可能的。我认为对于穆斯塔法·凯末尔来说，重要的是他失去了自己的出生地，而且再也没有拿回来。是的，当然。我的意思是，萨洛尼卡，塞萨洛尼基。无论如何，我们将
end with, since we love our Australian listeners, we should end with what it meant for Australia. And we were talking beforehand, weren't we, how some listeners would be surprised that three times as many British and Irish soldiers died at Gallipoli as Australians. Proportionately, is that the same, though? I imagine it's pretty similar. I would imagine it's pretty similar, but I'd have to check. The reason it's such a big deal in Australia and
结束，既然我们热爱我们的澳大利亚听众，我们应该以这对澳大利亚意味着什么来结束。我们之前在谈论，不是吗，一些听众会惊讶于在加里波利阵亡的英爱士兵人数是澳大利亚人的三倍。按比例来说，是一样的吗？我想这很相似。我想这很相似，但我得查一下。它在澳大利亚和
in New Zealand is that, first of all, it's the first time Australians have fought and died in such numbers. So it's not the first time they fought. Australians were in the Boer War, 20,000 of them, but only about 500 of them died. 250 from disease, 250 from Boer bullets or whatever. So to lose 8,000, if you're Australia, it's a really big deal. I mean, it's unprecedented in Australia's short history. The timing, the political context is really important because the Commonwealth of Australia, the Federation of the Colonies, had only happened in 1901. So the 1900s and 1910s were an age of basically inventing a nation, creating an Australian political and cultural identity distinct from British. So that's why Gallipoli plays such a big part in that, and people like Keith Murdoch,
在新西兰之所以如此重要，首先，这是澳大利亚人第一次如此大规模地战斗和牺牲。所以这不是他们第一次战斗。澳大利亚人参加了布尔战争，有2万人，但只有大约500人死亡。250人死于疾病，250人死于布尔人的子弹之类的。所以损失8000人，如果你是澳大利亚，这是一件大事。我的意思是，这在澳大利亚短暂的历史上是前所未有的。时机，政治背景非常重要，因为澳大利亚联邦，殖民地的联邦，直到1901年才实现。所以1900年代和1910年代基本上是一个发明国家、创造一种区别于英国的澳大利亚政治和文化认同的时代。所以这就是为什么加里波利在其中扮演了如此重要的角色，像基思·默多克这样的人，
the first reports I think mattered because they created this idea of Australian heroism and manhood and then it's such a shock when a few months later you have reports saying actually it's not all going according to plan and our boys who have been so heroic when they landed are actually being you know they're suffering horrendously and they're being cut down by Turkish machine guns and whatnot and then obviously in the years after the war people like Keith Murdoch they turn it, they turn Gallipoli into this kind of populist, patriotic fable. So you have brave, innocent, strapping, Anzax, and then you have effete,
我想最初的报道很重要，因为它们创造了这种澳大利亚英雄主义和男子气概的概念，然后几个月后，当你看到报道说实际上一切并没有按计划进行，而我们那些登陆时如此英勇的男孩实际上正在，你知道，遭受可怕的痛苦，被土耳其机枪扫射等等，这真是太令人震惊了，然后显然在战后几年，像基思·默多克这样的人，他们转变了它，他们把加里波利变成了这种民粹主义的、爱国主义的寓言。所以你有勇敢、天真、强壮的澳新军团士兵，然后你有虚弱的、
snobbish, arrogant, useless British officers. And that obviously is a stereotype that persists to this day, doesn't it? Well, I mean, you could say the other great kind of myth-building episode in Australian history is the bodyline tour when England and sends a cricket team to Australia. And they unleash this body line, so targeting the body with the cricket ball. And they win, England wins 4-1. But the Australians see this as absolutely kind of treacherous behavior.
势利的、傲慢的、无用的英国军官。这显然是一种至今仍然存在的刻板印象，不是吗？好吧，我的意思是，你可以说澳大利亚历史上另一个伟大的神话构建事件是“身体线”巡回赛，当时英国派了一支板球队到澳大利亚。他们释放了这种“身体线”，即用板球瞄准身体。他们赢了，英国以4比1获胜。但澳大利亚人认为这绝对是一种背信弃义的行为。
And they're captained by, he's actually Scottish, but Douglas Jardine, he becomes the kind of emblematic figure of a kind of uncaring, heedless, British ruthlessness that is simultaneously a feat. Yeah. And I think the kind of the sense of that with the notion of the British High Command at Gallipoli being incompetent and kind of heedless of slaughter is very kind of damaging for Britain's reputation in Australia. Definitely is. And it's an image that is carefully created by, for example, Australia's official war historian who is a man called Charles Bean, massive figure in kind of Australian historiography. Bean was the only war correspondent to be at Gallipoli throughout the whole campaign. And in the 1920s and 1930s, he wrote all these books and articles, saying that basically Gallipoli was the foundation of Australian identity.
他们的队长是，他实际上是苏格兰人，但道格拉斯·贾丁，他成为了那种冷漠、鲁莽、英国式无情的象征性人物，同时也是虚弱的。是的。我认为这种感觉，加上加里波利英国最高指挥部无能且无视屠杀的概念，对英国在澳大利亚的声誉非常有害。绝对是。这是一个由例如澳大利亚官方战争历史学家查尔斯·比恩精心创造的形象，他是澳大利亚史学界的一个大人物。比恩是整个战役期间唯一在加里波利的战地记者。在20世纪20年代和30年代，他写了所有这些书和文章，说基本上加里波利是澳大利亚认同的基础。
The big thing and the war for Australia was the discovery of the character of Australian men. It was character which rushed the hills at Gallipoli and held on there during the long afternoon and night when everything seemed to have gone wrong and there was only the barest hope of success. Anzac stood and still stands for reckless valour and a good cause for enterprise resourcefulness, fidelity, comradeship and endurance that will never own defeat. So it's this idea that Australians, they have the culture of mateship, of comradeship,
对澳大利亚来说，战争中的大事是发现澳大利亚男人的性格。正是这种性格冲上了加里波利的山丘，并在那个漫长的下午和夜晚坚持了下来，当时一切似乎都出了问题，成功的希望微乎其微。澳新军团代表并仍然代表着鲁莽的英勇和正义的事业，代表着进取心、足智多谋、忠诚、同志情谊和永不言败的耐力。所以这就是澳大利亚人拥有“伙伴情谊”、同志情谊的文化，
you never let your mates down, they have a sort of a fighting spirit, a simplicity, an honesty, a courage that the British have lost. and that's why I think there's such an appetite for that in this new country in the 1910s and 1920s and that's why it becomes completely enshrined
你永远不会让你的伙伴失望，他们有一种战斗精神、一种纯朴、一种诚实、一种英国人已经失去的勇气，这就是为什么我认为在1910年代和1920年代这个新国家里有如此大的需求，这就是为什么它被完全奉为神圣
and of course the 25th of April the day of the landings becomes a public holiday in Australia and New Zealand which it remains to this day so I had a look at the most recent Anzac Day 25th of April 2026
当然，4月25日，登陆日，在澳大利亚和新西兰成为了公共假日，至今仍然如此，所以我看了一下最近的澳新军团日，2026年4月25日
just a couple of weeks ago Anthony Albanese the Prime Minister of Australia issued a statement he said Anzac still stands for the courage, selflessness and mateship that define our national character. So it's basically exactly the message from the 1910s and 1920s. But Tom, we love our Australian and New Zealand listeners, don't we?
就在几周前，澳大利亚总理安东尼·阿尔巴尼斯发表了一份声明，他说澳新军团仍然代表着定义我们民族性格的勇气、无私和伙伴情谊。所以这基本上和1910年代和1920年代的信息完全一样。但是汤姆，我们热爱我们的澳大利亚和新西兰听众，不是吗？
We absolutely do. We absolutely do. So we wouldn't dream of disagreeing or undermining their sense of themselves? No. Just one kind of postscript to this. And again, it touches on cricket because cricket is so important as a metaphor for Anglo-Australian relations. But one guy who completely bought into this and weaponized it was Steve War, who was the remorseless captain of Australia's greatest test team. It just kind of repeatedly murdered
我们绝对热爱。我们绝对热爱。所以我们做梦也不会想到去反驳或削弱他们的自我意识？不。关于这一点的一个后记。同样，它触及了板球，因为板球作为英澳关系的隐喻非常重要。但有一个完全接受这一点并将其武器化的人是史蒂夫·沃，他是澳大利亚最伟大的测试队中冷酷无情的队长。它只是某种程度上反复屠杀了
England through the 1990s and the 2000s. And in May 2001, before the Ashes tour of that summer, he took the Australian team to the graves at Gallipoli to ponder the lessons of mateship. But of course, subliminally because they're then going on to play the England team, it's kind of buying into the idea of the British having been enfeebled in a feat and kind of faintly treacherous that puts the image of Australian mateship into a kind of even more heroic perspective, I think. It's not just about Australian mateship, it is also about how the British were useless. And I think that that is unfair on the British record of the, certainly of the men who were fighting there, because they seem to have been just as brave as the, as the Anzax.
英国，贯穿了20世纪90年代和2000年代。2001年5月，在那个夏天的灰烬杯巡回赛之前，他带着澳大利亚队去了加里波利的坟墓，思考伙伴情谊的教训。但当然，潜意识里，因为他们接下来要去和英国队比赛，这有点接受了英国人变得虚弱、虚弱且有点背信弃义的想法，我认为这把澳大利亚伙伴情谊的形象置于一个更加英雄主义的视角。这不仅仅是关于澳大利亚的伙伴情谊，这也是关于英国人是如何无用的。我认为这对英国的记录是不公平的，当然对于在那里战斗的士兵来说，因为他们似乎和澳新军团士兵一样勇敢。
I mean, totally. If you'd said that to the guys at Cape Hellies or at Suffler or whatever, you know, the Lancashire Fusiliers or the Munster Fusiliers or the Dublin's or any of these other people. Well, the Sandringham guys, you got abducted by aliens. Yeah. If you said to these guys, did you know that you were a feat and you're useless and you're weak and all this kind of thing? I mean, they would have been so shocked and offended that that would be their reputation after the war.
我的意思是，完全是。如果你对海丽斯角或苏弗拉或其他地方的人说，你知道，兰开夏燧发枪团或芒斯特燧发枪团或都柏林团或任何其他人。好吧，桑德灵厄姆的人，你被外星人绑架了。是的。如果你对这些人说，你知道吗，你很虚弱，你很无用，你很软弱，所有这些事情？我的意思是，他们会感到非常震惊和被冒犯，因为那是他们战后的声誉。
And it's completely undeserved. I mean, they died in massive numbers. They were just as brave. But thanks to things like the Mel Gibson film, it's very hard for them now to escape, you know, because there's nobody batting for them, as it were. I mean, it goes back to Churchill. It's the idea of patrician British figures.
这是完全不应得的。我的意思是，他们大量死亡。他们同样勇敢。但多亏了像梅尔·吉布森的电影这样的东西，他们现在很难逃脱，你知道，因为没有人在为他们辩护。我的意思是，这回到了丘吉尔。这是贵族英国人物的想法。
Yeah. Just being heedless. Kind of, you know, Churchill and Douglas Jardine kind of blur into a single toxic image of British Imperial Command. Well, so that's glippily. That's the end of our series about the first.
是的。只是无视。某种程度上，你知道，丘吉尔和道格拉斯·贾丁模糊成了一个单一的、有毒的英国帝国指挥形象。好吧，这就是加里波利。这是我们关于第一次世界大战系列的结尾。
First World War in 1915 and next year we will go on to 1916 and there's some very dramatic stuff in 1960. So there's a Battle of Jutland at sea and then the two Titanic battles of Verdun and the Somme and those of other stuff as well. But Tom, we've got a total change of pace and tone next week, don't we? Because the World Cup is upon us. Yeah. I mean, war by other means. So we are actually going to be focusing on something that has all. always been emblematic of nationalism, and that is the national anthems that are played at the start of each match. So it's not, I suppose, completely divorced from the spirit that drove the European Nations to war in the First World War. We might be looking at some of that,
第一次世界大战在1915年，明年我们将进入1916年，1916年有一些非常戏剧性的事情。所以有海上的日德兰海战，然后是凡尔登和索姆河这两场泰坦尼克式的战役，还有其他事情。但是汤姆，下周我们的节奏和基调完全变了，不是吗？因为世界杯就要到了。是的。我的意思是，通过其他手段进行的战争。所以我们实际上将关注一些一直以来都是民族主义象征的东西，那就是在每场比赛开始时播放的国歌。所以我想，这与第一次世界大战中驱使欧洲国家参战的精神并非完全脱节。我们可能会看看其中的一些，
because we're going to be looking at the star-spank or banner, at God Save the King, a host of other national anthems, and looking at how they emerged, what they tell us about the countries for which they're the anthem. So I think a really, really interesting way of celebrating the World Cup and of looking at some deep history. Yeah, it should be really fun. And Restus History Club members can hear those episodes first. So if you want to join them, sign up at the rest is history.com, which is, of course, the only way that you can access all the unbelievable benefits. Oh, they're unbelievable, aren't they? I mean, they're genuinely incredible. They're just literally unbelievable. But anyway, thank you, Dominic. That was, I mean, it was grueling,
因为我们将看看《星条旗》、《天佑国王》以及其他许多国歌，看看它们是如何出现的，它们告诉我们关于它们所代表的国家的信息。所以我认为这是一种非常、非常有趣的庆祝世界杯和审视一些深层历史的方式。是的，这应该会很有趣。历史俱乐部成员可以先听到这些剧集。所以如果你想加入他们，在“历史就是历史”网站注册，这当然是你获得所有难以置信的好处的唯一途径。噢，它们难以置信，不是吗？我的意思是，它们确实令人难以置信。它们简直是字面意义上的难以置信。但无论如何，谢谢你，多米尼克。那，我的意思是，那是一个艰苦的，
but brilliant series. Well, I mean, it is tough, isn't it, I think, the First World War? I do think it's tough. I mean, you kind of said at the beginning of this series, oh, it's kind of dramatic and it is dramatic, but it is, I share in Churchill's frustration. You know, I quite like it to be over. Oh, no.
但精彩的系列。好吧，我的意思是，这很艰难，不是吗，我认为，第一次世界大战？我确实认为这很艰难。我的意思是，你在本系列开始时说，噢，这有点戏剧性，它确实是戏剧性的，但它确实是，我分享丘吉尔的挫败感。你知道，我挺希望它结束的。噢，不。
Don't worry, there's only about three more, four more years of this to go. It is just people kind of, you know, maybe this will work out and they all end up dead on Bob. wire. Some people love that, some people don't. What can I say? Well, it's, I mean, it's, it's been a gripping series, a really gripping series. So thank you very much. And thank you everyone for listening. So, Alas Maladik. Goodbye. Hey, y'all, it's Kelly Clarkson with Wayfair. Ever order furniture online and wonder what if? Like, what if it doesn't hold up? That sofa was four days old. You should have ordered from Wayfair. With Wayfair, there's no what if. Just style you
别担心，还有大约三、四年就要结束了。这只是人们某种程度上，你知道，也许这会成功，然后他们都死在铁丝网上。有些人喜欢那样，有些人不喜欢。我能说什么呢？好吧，我的意思是，这是一个扣人心弦的系列，一个真正扣人心弦的系列。所以非常感谢你。也谢谢大家的收听。那么，再见。嘿，大家好，我是凯莉·克拉克森，代表Wayfair。有没有在网上订购过家具，然后想“如果……会怎样？”比如，如果它不耐用怎么办？那张沙发才用了四天。你应该从Wayfair订购。在Wayfair，没有“如果”。只有你
love and quality you can trust. Visit Wayfair.ca.cair, every style, every home. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
喜爱的风格和你可以信赖的质量。访问Wayfair.ca，每种风格，每个家。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。